so the atf
nominee guy david chipman he is
testifying before congress and he
doesn't even know how to define assault
weapon
he was asked several times and he's like
i can't answer that no it would take too
long and tom cotton's like you you want
us to write legislation to ban
these things and you don't know what it
is and he's like it's
um and then he said any semi-auto rifle
that takes something larger than a 22
which basically he basically said all
guns
or he said all rifles so this guy's
getting roasted we'll see if he actually
gets nominated because uh
i'm sorry if he actually gets confirmed
he might not and we got a bunch of other
stories too we got this this fouchy
thing which is really crazy and i feel
like we're kind of
it's it's it's rough because we're kind
of beating a dead horse but it keeps
escalating to the point where
i think we're on the verge of a massive
scandal fauci there there's this thing
called the fired act which is
fouchy incompetence requires early
dismissal or something like that
brilliant brilliant they want to fire
him we'll see if that actually happens
because republicans don't have that much
power
right now and uh well we'll get into
this stuff but i have to i have to uh
let you guys know or let's we're
watching live uh the power went out
because we got hit by a major storm and
because we here at teamcast ireland are
smart
we have a bunch of backup batteries
they're amazing beautiful little backup
batteries
and uh we should be good it's just
really really hot up here
and then uh you know the power might
come back on and then we'll run and plug
everything back into the
outlets or uh maybe the computer shuts
off because we run out of juice and
that's that's you can't win them all can
you so we'll uh we'll have a good time
we'll chill we got jack murphy's hanging
out hey i'm here before the power runs
out let me get a plug in
hey everybody i'm jack murphy subscribe
to my youtube channel we
are approaching 50 000 subscribers thank
you very much everybody really
appreciate it great to be here
someone on twitter said it is their
favorite night of the bye week
whatever that means i think in england
they call it a fortnight so here we are
this is every other wednesday jack
murphy on tim cast irl
with ian crossland yes and i got my
headset my headlamp just in case
the lights go out oh my gosh yeah we got
a daylight flashlight too it's really
really powerful
super bright it's super dark it was nuts
like
we were up here i got the ac going i was
going to be great you know jack's
chilling i'm like we're
it's we're in the highest point of the
building so it's like the temperature's
dropping and i'm like yes and then all
of a sudden the lights flicker and i'm
like well here we go hardcore too the
rain came
yeah hard and fast and all the lights
went out so the power's out like all
over like all the gas stations are out
yeah it's just us a little oasis of
battery powered youtube streaming
deliciousness that's awesome
incredible this is 21st century info
homesteading out in the wilderness
still able to broadcast to the universe
on the grids you want on
off of the grids you want off of that is
the dream
now there's another there's another
possibility that the internet battery
cuts out and then we're just gonna
run it all through the phone all of this
is going to get funneled down through
one teeny tiny little phone and out
there
that's how you tell the universe i wish
we could combine our phones to make a
mega network
like capture mesh or mesh them somehow
would you figure that out for me pretty
quick yeah yeah get on top right on top
of that yeah well i was driving in this
storm that was really fun it was like
driving through
just buckets of water people were
putting their four ways on and i was
like
why are you stopping if no one can see
you you are going to get hit by another
car so don't do that just keep moving
keep your lights on anyway yes
we're on top of a mountain basically
yeah like we're fairly elevated so you
know
cicadas are everywhere ever oh my god
i've been i i went outside
this morning for in like 10 minutes got
like 30 or 40 of them wow he was walking
up and going
just knocking him into a jar and then i
threw him in chicken city and like could
you imagine being a cicada or like could
you imagine like
being in a jar with a bunch of people
and someone throws you into a room full
of gigantic chickens
and they just start like like slamming
their faces
teen years for this
my dog has eaten so many of them she's
just barfing like crazy i can't
stop her dude she just like she keeps
eating them eating them and eating she
wants to play with them as soon as
they're dead she just eats them moves on
to the next
what kind of dog is it it is a pit bull
beautiful little pit bull oh you should
bring her up sometimes somebody somebody
was like it's the it's the one month
where you don't gotta buy chicken food
and i'm like it's crazy like like we
went out several times we probably got
100 cicadas
in in the span of 20 30 minutes you just
drop them in it got to the point where
the chickens stopped eating them i was
like man they're full and there was like
just the cicadas like
like because they peck them all and bash
them with their faces right so the
cicadas weren't going anywhere but then
like eventually they're just like i'm
i'm done
man it's like going to old country
buffet and you're loaded by mac and
cheese
you're just like dude i can't eat
anymore i know the food's there but
it's carcasses it's everywhere it's so
weird how
being extremely hungry is such a
horrible thing but then if you can eat a
lot really fast
you can't eat anymore all the chickens
were uncomfortably full yeah
where were the cicadas were they like on
the walls or on the
on the around on plants and like tree
branches and so i'm just walking up
with a jar and going wet and just like
bopping them into the jar and then
they're real dumb so they're just like
bouncing around in the dark they're not
even trying to leave
you know like the stink bugs at least
will like kamikaze they just like jump
off the wall and fall to the ground like
ah i gotta escape
17 years in the dirt dude 17 years
that's crazy but they sit underground
underground waiting tree roots
have you seen the holes in the ground no
no yeah they're like this big
crazy neck that's them crawling out
crawling out of the holes yeah
they're everywhere there's holes like
all right and they're like perfectly
circular and there's like a mound of
dirt on top of it like that gets pushed
out like an ant hill sometimes
crazy whoa it's great there's been
cicadas all over my coffee i was gonna
say
that's a cater cast somebody i saw
someone post on facebook is really funny
they're like can anyone explain to me
what's going on i hear like alarms going
off
yeah oh come on dude do you not really
well how about we talk about stuff
i thought that's what it was oh atf so
uh before we get started my friends you
must go
to our wonderful sponsor virtual shield
check out the link in the description
below
surfing internet safe by going to
surfing internetsafe.com
you can get virtual shield a virtual
private network for only two dollars and
50 cents
per month they say you get 50 off for
life if you get it at 59.88 for 24
months it's 77
off so it's even better let me explain
to you what a virtual private network is
it is
a way to provide basic security for you
while you browse the web
it funnels your internet through an
encrypted network makes it harder for
hackers and the government and nasty
people
from spying on you and collecting your
data it is a basic level of security so
the way i always explain it and most of
you probably have heard this but i'll
say it anyway
you know we don't expect anybody to
break in our house but we turn that
little lock on the window right
that little lock on the window is not
that good vpn's a bit better than that
but
it's a basic level of security you know
you're not going to walk around wearing
body armor in your own home but you're
going to lock your doors
and that's what you should do if you're
doing a lot of work you've got sensitive
data
a lot of people working remote now
you've got stuff that is important for
your business you're going to want to
you're going to want to be operating
securely so
vpns also do a bunch of other really
cool stuff with you know you can make
your you can make it appears that you're
coming from one country or another and
there's
there's cool things you can read about
that but uh but i'll leave it there go
to surfinginternetsafe.com
and you can get virtual shield 2.50
cents per month
thanks virtual shield for being a
sponsor and don't forget go to
timcast.com
hopefully the power will return at some
point during the show and we'll go yay
and then we'll return the
plugs to their outlets and then we'll
have a bonus segment bonus
i think we've got enough juice we have
like six of these batteries they're
amazing batteries
like these things yeah i was even
running the ac off of it for about 40
minutes
it had about 40 minutes fully charged
and that's that's pretty intense
i got some fans running right now but
anyway go to team guest.com become a
member
because you can get access to our
members only area but when you become a
member that that that funding you
provide that that 10
25 bucks a month whatever you give we're
using it to expand to hire more people
and we want to make something that
rivals all of these big networks we want
to be bigger than disney
and if we're going to do that we need we
need people to support so it's not just
that you get access to the members only
area
it's that you're helping build one of
the next big networks we're going to do
many docs we're going to do full
documentaries we're already i've already
spoken with someone about funding a tv
show some fiction some scripted
and some podcasts paranormal podcast we
got some political podcasts
all in good time with your support let's
talk about the news
man we got this story from the daily
mail republicans tear into biden's atf
pick for bungling definition of assault
rifles dodging questions about hunter
biden lying on his background check
and comparing gun owners to tiger king
in
car crash senate appearance wow yeah
david chipman was confronted by
republican senators during his
confirmation hearing
they excoriated the nominee on his
definition of assault weapons
refusing to commit to investigating
hunter biden and comparing gun owners to
tiger king
chipman deflected before saying an
assault weapon is quote
any semi-automatic rifle capable of
accepting a detachable magazine
above the caliber of 22 that is one of
the most insane things i've ever seen
this would include a 2-2-3 which is you
know largely the ar-15 round
i would say 556 but you know senator lee
brought up chipman's april 2020 comments
mocking first-time gun owners in the
midst of a panic
at the onset of the chronovirus pandemic
said at the time quote
they might think that their die hard
ready to go but unfortunately they're
more like tiger king
putting their family in danger this is
what i imagine like
darth vader would sound like you know
the empire and star wars
give up your weapons you morons and then
you know just taking them all away so
that people can't defend themselves
i think that they're going to do
everything that they can to get every
kind of weapon that they can that's why
the guy's not using any definitions he
wants to leave the door wide open as
possible but at the same time
what happened in texas recently
constitutional constitutional carry did
i read it with state number 21 or 22 or
something like that
i mean that is growing it's a trend i
can get behind you know in the 80s we
had less gun rights
did we really yeah that's crazy i was i
was i was researching the
constitutional carry it used to be in in
the 80s most states
were may issue for concealed carry that
means
they could deny you then many states
most states are shall issue meaning
they can make it difficult but they have
to give you the right to keep and bear
arms there's a lot of supreme court
rulings on this
there's a few jurisdictions but i think
maryland is the only
uh may issue state right now my favorite
thing about it though
is they have this map of the country and
it says there's a color quote it's like
green means constitutional carry and
there's tons of states
it means you can walk into west virginia
just have a gun just walk around you
can't brandish it at people obviously
but you can like walk around with big
guns and do whatever you want
well do whatever you want figuratively i
don't mean literally do whatever you
want
you can like walk around and do things
like go to the store and
unless someone you know complains then
you get the blue states
this the color code says blue shall
issue then you have the yellow may issue
and then the red
red so so i think hawaii and new jersey
are red
and it says may issue parentheses in
practice
won't issue so places like new jersey i
remember because we were there we were
in the philly suburbs
you try to apply for a gun and they'll
say what do you need a gun for
isn't that what heller in dc was all
about because that used to be the
application in dc used to be
explain your reasons for needing a
concealed carry
now it's like if you want to tell us you
can tell us
but they they can't use it as a
condition anymore i thought that was a
supreme court decision shouldn't
have struck down those ones in new
jersey and hawaii in that case i don't
know
they they act like their may issue but
they're no issue yeah so so i went to
maybe that's it maybe like oh okay we're
may issue we're not
we're gonna we're gonna issue they don't
so i was told by everybody
you know in maryland and new jersey you
basically will say here's my reason for
needing it or i deal with large
transactions i run a business i'm high
profile
maryland apparently will say okay new
jersey apparently will be a like nah
can't do it you can't even pump your own
gas in new jersey i know
yeah yeah you got you you pull up and
they do it for you so if you were like i
want to defend myself against
potentially tyrannical government
they'll they won't give you a gun yeah
i'm pretty sure they
probably don't if you if you say like
exercising my second amendment rights
they tell you goodbye
later heck yeah dude but this is this is
the crazy thing uh
this atf guy it's it's interesting we
see these stories
the stupidity of this man and the the
sheer like
what's the right word villainous i mean
the guy looks
evil he looks like a if i was if i was
casting a star wars movie i'd be like
that's the emperor guy like that's going
to be
working for the empire the way he looks
the way he talks he has listened to the
permanent frown on the sides of his
mouth or like downward like mitch
mcconnell
some people have that and it's he needs
a mustache though so he can twirl it
while he's doing these
things i'll take all their guns i
definitely
uh as i encounter more and more people
and have greater life experience i come
to understand that iq and intelligence
is definitely on a curve there's a
distribution of all these things there's
plenty of stupid people out there
i'm afraid to continue to apply
stupidity to what
is actually malice right
that guy knows what he thinks an assault
rifle is yeah but he won't say it right
like you said right he's not being
stupid he's actually being very
calculating and smart about it there was
a there was one point i think like two
years ago where they said an assault
weapon was
any weapon that that was semi-auto and
took a detachable magazine
so look what he's saying right did he
said he said rifle in this instance so
he's not talking about handguns
but they actually included in one of
their one of the democrats included in
one of their bills that hand guns would
be an assault weapon like a glock 17.
i remember i went down to the march for
our lives and i asked people
they were like ban assault weapons and i
said do you know the definition of an
assault weapon like honest question i'm
just doing interviews
and they were like yeah you know like
the ar-15 these rifles
and i said are you aware that current
legislation proposed by democrats would
ban a glock 17
and they'd say oh what is that that's
the handgun i'm like that's what police
use i believe please use block 17.
it's a very common handgun and they're
like no no that's that's that's that's
that's not right and i'm like well
that's what you're advocating for right
now
i saw one lady only a sign that said ban
assault rifles and i was like what do
you mean by
ban assault rifles and she's like i
don't think assault rifles should be you
know people should be able to go and
just like buy them and i was like
but they can't it's like they're nf
they're they're heavily restricted to
nfa items it's already
you know impossible to get they don't
really make them anymore she didn't know
anything about it
so she just like folded up her she's
like oh i didn't realize you know
you disrupted the protest by your
like journalist actual just regular
questions
i mean look obviously when you go to
these protests for gun stuff
i think most people are are they know
these people have no idea what they're
talking about
and so you can approach these people
like hey you're really dumb tell me why
you're so dumb and look stupid for the
camera
i didn't i'm not gonna do that i was
just like i noticed you wanted to ban
assault rifles
well uh i'm curious the the national
firearms act basically banned all
assault rifles as defined you know by
the atf select fire rifles however you
describe it so these are basically
heavily restricted and you typically
don't find them in gun shops at all
anymore so i'm not sure like
do you did you want to get rid of the
the the uh grandfathered in
nfa items and they're just like they
have no idea well most people don't know
anything most people
are ignorant there was a rationality to
being ignorant in the sense that you
could have no
impact on these outcomes and then the
impact on you is usually going to be
very small
unfortunately the government reach and
they're the creep into every aspect of
our life and everything has gotten so
great
that that er that rationally ignorant
balance i feel like is getting out of
whack you need to
know more it will affect your life in a
way that it didn't affect you and you
need to be able to take action
what's interesting increasing
constitutional carry states
it's the choices are very clear now like
i'm going to miami next week i can't
wait the free state of florida
is that constitutional carry uh i don't
know i don't know that's that social
media thing
they passed social media thing it's
totally wide open it's going to be a
great time i'm so excited about going
getting out of dc but my point is is
that like people are moving
i know a lot of people that have moved
people that are migrating people that
are literally taking their
lives and putting them in the place
where they're going to have
representation that meets
with their desires and their
expectations and john rob
a great military strategist and analyst
uh uh
he's talking very regularly and mike
anton as well from claremont
uh in hinsdale hillsdale talking very
clearly right now about
like maybe we should be resorting the
states maybe we should be moving
counties from one state to another maybe
we should be going eastern oregon
joining greater idaho maybe south
western in western virginia joining west
virginia i'm sure there's a number of
this is hyper this is hyper hyper
polarization
so yeah people are moving and and we see
in northern colorado and northern
california in eastern oregon they want
to move their counties together
the state of jefferson is one proposal
or great greater idaho is would
incorporate
that as well then you have the one
county in northern colorado that wants
to join i think what is it wyoming yeah
because of like cattle ranching and
stuff that just that's just hyper
polarization
you know there's precedent though this
has happened before massachusetts used
to be all of new england practically and
how many states are up there now
the uh the there was one other instance
um west virginia and virginia for
example now civil war
it was pre right well no no it was the
civil war
so as the civil war was kicking off west
virginia western virginia was like nah
we ain't we don't want to be a part of
that so west virginia was north and
virginia was south
split split the state in half
rearranging rearranging counties among
states don't i don't think would take
constitutional
amendment or i don't even federal
approval based on the article that i
read from michael anton
uh just the other day i don't think that
matters why not i think if a county says
we hereby decide that we the people
choose different governance
the united states should oblige they
should they should oblige but there are
rules to joining the union and
i think one of them is that you can't
just make whole you know states out of
nothing so no no no no right right so
joining us is just specifically about
rearranging counties into existing
states
i encourage that why not it's happened
before representation of the people that
you want
there's no reconciling these issues that
we have these are fundamentally opposed
diametrically opposed
irreconcilable philosophies and
ideologies and that will precipitate
full-on hot civil war or or
union collapse so right now oregon
there the eastern eastern oregon is not
being represented by
portland and eugene right and i guess
is vancouver part of uh oregon it's like
north of portland
that's north of seattle vancouver no no
no no there's a there's a vancouver in
washington and in canada oh it's
washington i'm thinking of seattle
yeah just north of seattle oh okay
really
yeah i believe i don't know we're only
live on the air with hundreds of
thousands of people i could be wrong
wouldn't be the first cops
this is i feel the same way about jersey
is that like all this jersey legislation
is basically newark in like jersey city
they're
it's representing new york the new york
suburb oh all the rest of new jersey is
getting hit with this ridiculous
legislation
it it is washington but it's just north
of portland so we were both right oh
yeah vancouver washington is just north
of portland so but anyway how often
these are it's it's very similar it's
basically the same metro so but but it's
not oregon
so these eastern counties are not being
represented so they say we want to join
idaho where we will be
well at the very least there's some
political pressure right
very little but some so the politicians
that come
out of you know eastern oregon still are
like well we can't
do absolutely anything we want because
we have some pushback from eastern
oregon but for the most part
they're powerless to stop us you get rid
of them and they're going to say now
we're completely unrestrained
and have no reason to do any compromise
at all period for any reason
it's possible they'd also have less
electoral power they
why would they have less electoral power
well if we're we're not talking about
counties adding themselves to blue
states we're talking about red counties
democrats would never win again
democrats are we're talking about red
counties subtracting themselves from
blue states and adding them to red
states which would increase the
electoral power of the red state
decrease the electoral power of the blue
state which means
they'll never let it happen if the
democrats have any power about it
they'll never let it happen
although all of a sudden i've been
struck by some great compromise that's
going to involve greater idaho
jefferson state uh a greater west
virginia a district of columbia state
puerto rico as a state
this is the way that politics gets done
negotiation compromise who knows maybe
that maybe that
maybe that comes down the road but that
would be uh an artifact of a functioning
white republic with negotiations
compromise why would the
the wealthy elites in oregon give up
their serfs well right no
it would have to it's not
they won't this is going to be the issue
right yes normally a ground-up movement
so perhaps the reason you get the
democrat
establishment and look very much so many
of the neocons
who want guns banned oh but you know i'm
a conservative but reasonable gun
control i'm a hunter i don't think we
should have ar-15s when i
served in the marines you know that one
guy marine guy on
on on uh twitter who was like an hr
administrator
and then says this is the weapon issue
to me a weapon of war and it's like bro
bro calm down
like you did hr okay i respect it you
know because we you know serving as
serving but
you need humans m-16s not ar-15s you
need to calm down and so but you know
they they very much want to take weapons
away because
then it's a steamroll yeah then it's a
steam roll so this is interesting
uh there was a meme posted where
somebody you know some lefty
some democrat was like nobody's coming
to take your guns blah blah blah and i'm
like they already did are you talking
about
literally already did so i i so when you
live on the border of
when you're between three states
virginia west virginia and maryland you
know all about how they've taken your
guns away
because i go to i go to the gun shop
crowder uh for instance sends me the sig
m400
you can't bring it to maryland it's not
legal so if you live in maryland you
literally cannot buy a bunch of
regular guns not even crazy guns there's
just random things that are banned and
you're like i don't know why
but they've banned them already now what
they're not doing is taking them from
you
the problem is what they do is they'll
they'll ban it and then say
if you've owned it before this date
you're good you know the problem with
that is
share if that beauty shows up to your
house the uh you got an m1a
well i found it for i don't know it's
illegal man yes but the law says i don't
care man you're under arrest to give me
your weapon
you think these guys know anything about
what that means what the law is no it's
an affirmative defense meaning after
they take your weapon and charge with a
felony for having an assault weapon
you can then go to court and make your
and plea to the judge please
i i had it before 2013. do you have a
receipt
it's it's been almost it's been eight
years i don't have a receipt for this
lock them up so keep your receipts and
then go to the gun store and get
copies of your receipts if they don't
have it anymore but think about the game
they're playing
it's it's meant to obstruct as much as
possible
so now you know what this dude said this
atf guy he was like i
i he mentioned to uh marcia i think it
was marcia blackburn
that we should make all of all rifles
nfa items
like there you go that solves the
problem the same guy said that yeah
this is so i'm with ignorance man no
it's not ignorance no no no
people that are ignorant in the united
states that are witnessing this are not
they don't realize how dangerous and
idiotic this guy
sounds and seems to be acting you mean
evil yeah if he's he's feigning
ignorance that's evil
but if you and if you're actually
ignorant it's just dangerous idiocy
tunic to an extent uh for uh but let me
clarify to for those that don't
understand the national firearms act
basically they they they contin they
regularly put items on this list
it takes you like nine months on average
depending on who you have to say
six months to a year to be able to buy
one suppressors for instance
these are nfa items you want to get one
takes a really long time so i'm i'm
in the process of buying some and it's
been i think like three weeks
and so now i've got to wait for like an
atf transfer from ffl to ffl
then i've got to get the paperwork to
start the process so this is an extended
process because of shipping which will
take
just over a year to get and what people
need to understand
first silencers are not real like
there's nothing you put on a gun and
goes pew pew pew
suppressors drop the the sound enough
to where if you're outside you you'd
probably be okay without wearing
ear protection but you still want to
wear ear protection it just reduces
recoil it makes it safer
you know you i i talk to a bunch of
instructors and and a lot of uh
experts and competitive shooters and
like it definitely makes it safer it
makes it
the recoil is better and for you in your
home wanting to defend your home
people people need to realize this
you're sitting inside you're sleeping in
your bed
you hear glass shatter in your house so
you grab you know your handgun or
whatever you fire that in your house
without your protection what are you
going to do
you wake up in the middle of the night
someone breaks in your house you grab
your shotgun and then you grab your
earpro and your eye pro and you're like
good to go
no you're going to grab it and be like
boom and everyone's ears are going to go
you get suppressors and it makes it
better better well these are these are
nfa items
why because people are dumb because they
see movies where the guy goes
and then everyone's like i didn't hear a
thing and then people believe movies
tools of assassination they believe
movies they like man you don't want to
be in a room
like it's when a gun goes off because
your ears are going to be ringing you're
going to be like why i can't hear
anymore
but people watch movies and they and
they they pass
laws based on movies and i think that's
a really good description of democrats
we were talking with uh
we were talking with you know we had
scott horton on the show the other day
and after the show you know we're
hanging out we had a mini ramp session
it was pretty sick i did a kickflip
pivot it was awesome
uh we were talking about the policies of
the democratic establishment
and i think andreas was saying like
they're centrists or he mentioned that
and i was like dude they're not
centrists and he was
scott was saying i think they are
they're like corporatists and i'm like
dude
hillary clinton no politics she says
things that she thinks will get her
elected whatever she has to say
there's no ideology in there now there's
leftists who are like we must have this
and we must have the
you know universal health care and and
cooperative economics then you have the
right wing where they're like you know
free market is better and individual
responsibility
these are people who believe in things
left or right economically traditional
versus progressive
then you have the establishment
democrats who are like what do i have to
say to attract the largest group of
people to vote for me
i'll say that okay there's no there's no
ideology there there's no that's not
centrist
simply being like i'll say whatever i
have to say is not centrism
a centrist is someone who's like
conservatives got a good point about you
know individualism
but i do think the left makes a good
point that we can't have people just
dying in the street like how do we how
do we solve for that
centrists are just like you know kind of
seeing like yeah let's get some good
ideas right i've got some good ideas
there there were centrists there were
and our political differences
were about policy because
both the democrats and the republicans
came with an appreciation of the
constitution
i thought maybe my history is a little
shaky probably look into it it probably
wasn't as
rosy as you might expect but it seems to
me now
though that like we said earlier
irreconcilable
first principles of these ideologies now
that make
a center impossible what is it is it the
war
is it like some people are okay with
with conquest and some people aren't
there there's like it's not a left or
right there's another
so this is what i'm thinking it's it's
not left and right anymore i know the
political compass has authoritarian
libertarian economic left economic right
but the damage the neolibers the neocons
are not left or right they're not
they're the corporate uniparty
and they don't have they they don't care
for for
any kind of ideological agenda they
don't care about a free market
they'll support the free market insofar
as it gives them power they don't care
about regulation
they'll support regulation insofar as it
gives them power
they want to blow up people they want to
blow up kids why because they can sell
weapons the highest bidder they can
build oil pipelines they can dominate
different regions and get more power
they're like fascists you know to
varying degrees but
it's it's not even necessarily
fascinating because there's no
underlying ideology other than
give me more i want so you've got
leftists who
i disagree with but at least they
believe things
wrong things things you can actually
point to the establishment doesn't care
they'll say whatever
they have to say i think that somebody
might
argue that greed is in itself an
artifact of free market capitalism right
like there's varying levels of greed
greed or desire or want to acquire
resources
we want to require resources to sustain
our families and have some luxury time
and take vacations and retire early and
enjoy our lives
hopefully a little bit more than that
it's it's just i think the same
scale to think from that i want to be
able to do whatever i
i can do and then you know more power
more money more power more
i was just studying the the kelsey so
i'm sorry just self-centered greed in it
of itself
is isn't adam smith saying this is the
the key to everything that we've got
going on in a
liberal open economic system let's look
i i have a good example of this and for
our next story check this out
so fox news democrats are getting
increasingly
nervous about woke culture analysts say
james carville says wokeness is a
problem and everyone knows it
interesting james i didn't see him you
know coming out and speaking about this
before the election why say whatever
they have to say to gain power
now that they realize there's a
competing power hungry fascistic
ideology
now they're worried about it but many of
these woke leftists
aligned themselves with neocons and
neolibs because orange man bad
many many leftists democratic socialists
also aligned themselves
what a truly powerful coalition of
people who have no business supporting
each other
just because they hated trump they were
able to form that alliance now trump is
gone
now it's all falling apart but but the
wokeness is
uh a very very real problem for
democrats because it's starting to
supplant the establishment
they're forced to adopt a lot of this
nonsense a lot of this ridiculous
rhetoric
and joe biden is the epitome epitome of
old white men
somehow they got the woke to vote for
him but now they're recognizing it's
going to cause them increasing
increasing problems moving forward with
with these elections joe biden's always
been woke joe biden is the one that
kicked off the title
ix reform that stripped away due process
for men and people anyone accused of
harassment
on campus because he believed the sjws
who went in there crying about rape
crisis rape one and four one in four
it was joe biden himself who pushed the
2011 thing
which really opened up the floodgates
for all this woke crap to get into for
all the administrative elements of our
universities
from there they trained all of these
students who went into the corporations
and now they're transforming the
corporations
so really joe biden has been the avatar
of woke the leader of woke
the biggest enabler of woke since
as far back as i can remember in the
early parts of the obama administration
which is totally ironic given his past
comments and his beliefs about
segregation in schools and all these
things it's it's interesting
but he's always been a tool for them and
man it's guys like andrew sullivan
man that burns me up i know because
andrew sullivan correctly identifies the
problem with woke
he understands critical race theory is a
problem he understands the racism he
understands how it turns into
anti-semitism
he didn't care all he wanted to do was
get rid of trump
yep he did not care he is supposed to be
somebody with some sense of reason like
a sane voice out there
at least that's how i remember him when
i was a kid and i wasn't too politically
informed but i would watch him on bill
maher and i'd be like
well he's the conservative one and i
like him better than all the rest of
them
so i remember him and i remember him
writing an article in 2000 about
testosterone replacement therapy
where he acknowledges the power of
hormones in driving personality and
behavior and expression of self etc
so he understands and has known for a
long time but he was unwilling
to stand up for it he was willing to
support
and advocate for joe biden to accept the
wokeness
simply to get rid of donald trump and
for that man
just sacrifice everybody burn it down
because this guy's got mean tweets mean
tweets
good policies good policies but mean
tweets oh but mean tweets man
i know hey what am i what am i gonna
tell my kids you know he he tweeted that
that lady was a horse face
of course that was funny actually rosie
o'donnell wasn't that
woody on you period oh gosh
he called he called stormy horse face he
tweeted that right he did wow
he did hilarious yeah not but
you know mean tweets mean tweets bad but
hey like what double the amount of kids
kept in cages on the border right now
how much is the increase the surge of
people who are from streaming across the
border
it's it's literally the spongebob meme
dude where patrick and spongebob are
like the
city's on fire and pat and spongebob is
like we did we saved the city that's
that's what it is
yeah they they they trump represented
something
you know it was it was a clever play by
the establishment they did it
there was a combination of milking media
and uh the democrats being like we want
to win so
we'll do whatever we have to do and it
started before he even took office
oh yeah it was nuts it was nuts yeah
so i wanted to mention i saw this really
funny video from babylon b
where it's a bunch of clan members and
they're discussing like
how like hey the media is saying like
you know racism is back in so like it's
time to get back into the game
and then one of them is like no no you
don't got to do anything anymore you're
a white male
just literally just be and you're racist
you're you're good
and then the the leader of the dragon
he's like he's like what what do you
mean he's like no i want things
and then he starts naming things and
they're like yeah but that's not racist
anymore
to say this so he was like what about
segregation like no no no the left says
that's good now
so it ends with this clan member like
going to a university and demanding
segregated water fountains
and then a woke guy walks up and goes
that's really forward thinking man i
respect
that that's that's that that's like
that's where we are that's where we are
i saw an interview with uh christopher
ruffo on uh oh mark lamont hill
on vermont hello i saw that okay and
lamont hill
tried to mark right whatever he tried to
back and bait roofo into answering a
question that would have would have
broken his frame and the question
it was like well can you say anything
nice about white people
no no hold on hold on rufo said that
this critical race theory is cl is is
attacking what they describe as
whiteness
saying it's a very negative thing we
shouldn't be doing that yes and then he
said
oh okay if if uh if you think they're
saying it's a negative thing then what's
one thing you like about being a white
man right and rufo
said i you know i i don't see it that
way i don't agree with that and so then
he goes no no just humor me just humor
me
and then rufus said i reject the premise
of
of your claims about whiteness and i
want you to treat me like an individual
as much as you know i would treat you
and then he tweeted something roofo
tweeted something that was brilliant
he responded to marcelotte hill saying
you and i have substantially more in
common the same language the same
country
much you know uh say like similar income
level in class
more so than i would have in common with
a swedish farmer
and more so than you would have with a
nigerian farmer
that's that that was an amazing point
that he made about wokeness and critical
race theory
that i think most of us already realize
right obvious right
because of what they're not they're not
attacking whiteness
they're just calling it that they're
just attacking american culture
period that's it yeah my favorite thing
was like
what what he said okay well if i have to
you know use critical race theory then
perhaps being on time and working hard
and then a bunch of people on twitter
like no one defines whiteness that way i
saw
i was right there on all that and so
this this is absolutely produced they do
though
they do they do define that that's
exactly how they define it oh there's
absolutely no question that white
supremacy white dominance culture is
defined by
punctuality reliance on data
self-reliance individualism rugged
individualism objectivity
science all kinds of things right
a desire to be safe yeah right
uh but it brings up an interesting point
um chris
you know i love you chris i've had chris
on the show a number of times he's a
tremendous guy
he he has a he has a role that he's
playing he's
incredibly effective and he's got huge
amounts of change
i am a little bit different than him i
might have actually doubled down
when they asked that question i would
have been like hell yeah i love a
million things about being white i love
being on time
i love being myself i love taking care
of myself and being responsible for
everything about me and
not needing handouts whatever yeah but
that's interracial marriage
that's not gonna work because the the
general audience doesn't know anything
about it
so if you come out as this you know
indeed
they don't know anything about it they
also didn't know anything about it when
chris answered the way he did at least
the way that i would have done it is a
very
tried and proven technique called agree
and amplified
when someone asks you a question that's
clearly meant to be provocative or to
challenge you
the only response is to take what
they're accusing you of
and just come back and say yes times 10.
so what i would do
is i would pull up the african-american
heritage museum and i would say
well not that i agree with your view
uh mark which i believe is a white
supremacist worldview but i did pull up
this article from the african-american
heritage museum which says
that being on time is a trait of
whiteness see i reject that premise but
based on your you want me to humor your
ideology your white supremacist ideology
oh i would agree with you on that i
suppose that being on time is a good
thing
i would however disagree that it's
whiteness to be on time because i'm
pretty sure you are on time
the funniest part of all right is like
that guy
is punctual takes care of himself he
doesn't want to hand out doesn't want
anybody to help him he believes in the
power of personal effort and
responsibility
and data you don't think that guy's
looking at ratings
geez louise so the whole thing is absurd
and it's like i'm ready just to agree on
amplify now
today on twitter i was like crt is
absolutely right man
this white culture this is what it is
and it's great and it's the best culture
that it is and look what it's created
and here we are
i agree it's it's look just
google search critical theory i know and
this thing that you reference about the
american african-american heritage
museum
the last thing on that they took it down
right because it was so
insane that it was like a clan like a
clan member it was insane that our
federal tax money paid for this thing
and was publicly posted by the
government where since the 90s where the
last
thing about anti-racist is
i yield positions of power to people of
color
that is what they want specifically
in the literature you white person yield
your position to you
person of color why to take care of
history and all these terrible things
and blah blah blah
and because you've got your power and
you don't so you have to get out of the
way that's what they're teaching your
kids
that's what they're teaching your
children in school i mean it's it's it's
step aside beyond grace do you want your
children to be told to yield positions
of power that they may have earned
through hard work and dedication
perhaps i'm getting hot it's well beyond
race though this is one of the issues i
have with the constant saying critical
race theory over and over again
is that critical theory is much larger
than that right it's it's it
it encompasses science they say science
isn't real
so we say critical race theory we say
critical race theorists believe there's
no critical
theorists believe this and it's it's
much much more than just race
right they tell your kids that two plus
two equals five
yeah what are they going to do now that
it's becoming evident that they actually
are the institutional power they're
going to have to
eject half of their philosophical
background because
it's specifically about attacking people
in power no no they don't
they they don't because they come out
they say it and
cowards regular americans are who are
cowards just accept it even though they
know they have institutional power come
on hollywood is not
pressed hollywood's opinions the
democrats are not oppressed you're
missing my point i'm talking about the
philosophical underpinning the reference
has always been a lie always been a liar
so when they come out and they say we're
still oppressed oh come on they were
claiming
donald trump as the power structure of
this country just donald trump whose own
staff he had hired people who hated him
john bolton hated him he hired a bunch
of idiots he should have fired a bunch
of other idiots and he had no control
over cultural institutions
so you had every news organization
except fox news even sometimes fox news
you had the republican establishment
opposed to i mean the democratic
establishment hollywood
you had all the major corporations and
they claimed trump was the power yeah
yeah no i agree we're talking about two
different things i totally i understand
you're saying the philosophy but my
point is
they had they came out at a time when
they already were the institutional
authority in every respect
and said we're the marginalized now
there's been a slight change a few seats
have flipped in congress
and now they're still saying the same
thing well right but but this is this is
a
50-year process right so these changes
about them actually taking over
institutional control are really in like
the eighth and ninth inning of this game
that's already been going on for a long
time
so all my whole my only point here is
that the hypocrisy that you're pointing
out is just becoming a little bit more
obvious
a little bit more evident and that when
they use their philosophical studies in
literature to justify what they're doing
they're actually going to have to eject
part of the foundation that they've been
using
as justification for their actions which
is demonstration of the fact that it was
all bullcrap
in the first place and we're gonna see
that i think moving forward they don't
have to eject the philosophy
why okay why would they have to i'm
talking about the theorists and the
people that the academics and the ones
that write papers based on papers based
on papers with references and such
but but what i don't understand is that
they've been lying the whole time so why
would they change anything
good point don't know they they
they control the colleges the movies the
tv shows
the political establishment the banking
institutions now the federal reserve is
woke
numerous federal reserve banks are now
embracing wokeness
joe biden is doing race-based rep
race-based recovery acts let's say
reparations they just flaunt it while
still
saying that the homeless white veteran
sleeping in the gutter is the oppressor
and oprah winfrey is oppressed
it's always been ludicrous on its face
it's just an excuse to manipulate the
emotions of dumb people who don't pay
attention
and you know what i'll give a special
shout out to bill burr who exemplified
this so perfectly
when he was on the joe rogan experience
and he was like
i'm not gonna do this with you joe sit
here with you who has no medical degree
and i have no medical medical degree
talking about what we should do
i turn on the tv once every two weeks
and i and i do what the tv says
thank you yeah he's he's so so smart
disturbing did you see him on conan a
few days ago
no he did some really really obnoxious
stuff he exemplifies the problem
i don't care about this country i don't
care about this planet i don't care
about you
i'm just gonna turn the tv on once every
two weeks and do what it tells me to do
talk about giving up your responsibility
talk about being a wealthy dude
extracting from the system and saying
f.u to all the hard-working people who
are like please help us
this the room's on fire and he's like i
don't know i come in once every two
weeks and i do what the guy the door
tells me he said he wished more people
had died from covet on conan
what was like what it was really
disturbing he was like yeah you know the
stupid
like like it was really really he's
allowed to make jokes it wasn't
i mean it wasn't funny whatever i was
saying was ridiculous you know
when when he's when he's exemplifying
one of the biggest problems in this
country
and that's regular people say i don't
know i don't care i don't want to know
and i don't want to care
and then it's like okay then what do
they do they punch each other in the
parking lot over a can of beans
they there was a when the gas shortage
hit a video of a of a guy punching them
in the face bro do you see this this is
what happens when you ignore
everything i was talking about this the
other day several times now with fouchy
friends let's give you a good
i'll give you a good example fauci goes
on the tv and he's like you don't need
to be wearing masks you know
if you it might protect you from a
droplet or two
and then later a few months later he's
like oh i lied on purpose because we
wanted doctors to get it
and so my point was if fauci came out
and said just wear a scarf
people would have worn scarves but he
was worried doctors wouldn't get masks
but if people just wore scarves and
masks then the doctors would have
not have needed as many masks the point
is because no one paid attention to what
this
[ __ ] was saying they they ignored
sound policy when you had when you had
china buying up all the ppe
you had fauci be like no don't do it and
then people died
and then the doctors now need more masks
if people were paying attention
they wouldn't be fighting each other in
the parking lot for a can of beans
or punching somebody for some toilet
paper instead
they don't care they don't accept their
responsibility and they just
they just ignore it and then we we sit
here watching the place burn down it's
like we're in the titanic it's sinking
and we're like yo we need help and
they're like nah i'm good
bill imagine this your boat sinking
right you're on a big ship it's filling
with water and you're like you know what
it's a slow leak it's getting faster but
if everybody bails water
we're going to make it and then bill
burr walks in and goes look i just walk
in the room once every two weeks
and i look at the guy who's sitting in
the in the captain scene just do what he
tells me and the guy in the captain see
fouch he's just saying random stuff you
don't even know what he's talking about
so this guy then goes that's the
attitude all these americans have
we we have seen with the culture war
with gamergate with critical race theory
we have all been watching this happen
since the early 2010 since the late
to you know you look at the data from
zach goldberg and alexis and lexus nexus
and you can see the the massive
explosion of critical race theory and
then we start you know ringing the bells
and people say shut up i don't care the
media lies for sure
yeah it manipulates people but it really
comes down to this
if people just say i'll turn the tv on
once every two weeks and do what it
tells me
then it doesn't matter what we know
these people keep voting for this stuff
i have friends
who i want one friend of mine he films
himself walking with like a fur
a pov shot of the ballot going to the
mailbox saying you've got to do what's
right for this country and vote for joe
biden
and when i said what does that mean vote
for joe biden he's just like
well you know trump's bad why is trump
bad what policy what are you talking
about he doesn't have any
he doesn't have it he turns the tv on
once every two weeks they say orange man
bad every time so he says okay
i'll go do what i have to do burn the
country down and throw another
another molotov cocktail into our
buildings our capital buildings our
institutions
and then come and complain that me with
the water i'm the problem it's they
called the the plebeians
the plebians is that what they were
called ancient rome i was just watching
this this reconquest of the roman empire
by um
what was that emperor's name but anyway
he went around and and
re reconquered most of the empire that
had been flowing around 250 a.d
most of people didn't care the citizens
of the cities they just they just
changed their flag they'd be like oh
okay a new a new leader take the old
flag down but they didn't want to die
they didn't want to get conquered they
want to get hurt
they just go along with it that's like
98 percent of the people
i have i have a lot of sympathy for
people that don't have the luxury that
we have of spending time
figuring this stuff out every day and it
is
very common and totally reasonable for
people
to not have that much time to dedicate
to processing consuming information
and this is why we're in such a
critically dire circumstance
because most people don't even check in
with the news because they can't
because they're working hard they're
trying to figure out how to feed their
three kids and deal with virtual school
and go to work and deal with gas
shortages and deal with corona and all
these things
it's hard enough but it's getting to the
point where
the institutions are so corrupted that
there's
zero reason to trust there was reason to
trust
so we're at this part where there's like
this uh tectonic
uh pressure building where it's like oh
it was okay to be ignorant and
rationally ignorant over here because
everything was okay and
moving in this direction is it's lethal
now to be rationally ignorant
and it's kind of there's faults
happening there's little faults
happening
sooner or later there's going to be an
eruption if this thing turns out
muhan institute of virology and fauci's
involved in
advance to function or who know i don't
know what i'm talking about
the point is is like if this if there's
a real huge
massive scandal that comes out of this
it
may wake some people up but i still
don't know
how to solve the problem for the dual
working
family with multiple kids and 50
different after school activities
and group think and just not having the
luxury of time to dedicate
i deal with this with my ex-wife all the
time because we're talking about all
kinds of issues
and she's like well how do you know it's
my job to know
i literally get paid every day to learn
and figure this stuff out
break it down synthesize it and then
explain it to people
it's my job let's i'm lucky for that
let's talk about the
the real world ramifications for for you
and your loved ones so uh i
i agree with with jack so uh for those
just tuning in we were talking
about you know people who don't pay
attention to the news
and you made a good point that i've
often brought up it's not the job of the
average person to focus on news and
politics
a carpenter's job is to build and to
help people live and be more comfortable
and hvac
you know employees they're going to help
you have your your air
functioning properly not not watching
the news you know we're sitting there
very hot
well we got the hvac guys working on it
right now yeah
so uh so here's the news the trial of
kyle rittenhouse over the deadly
wisconsin shootings slated to begin
november 1st
and last up to two weeks so
it we're we're getting there this is a
an update but there's a lot
yeah there's going to be riots they're
going to burn buildings down
kyle rednoughs will get life in prison i
don't know for sure
i don't know for sure you said it you
were so confident when you said it but
uh uh it's going to happen i don't know
i said
kyle rittenhouse will get life in prison
i don't know for sure
why do you think that do you think the
media manipulation will push because
regular people
unfortunately too many of them are
cowards
that's like the nature of humanity even
even during even during the revolution
a large portion a large portion the
plurality the plebeians
and carry the rocks for you and that's
why you have a republican government
that's why democracy as defined by
just mob rule doesn't work and that's
what we have right now
public the republic is gone so here's
what's going to happen they're going to
do jury selection
these people are going to be there and
they're going to be like i don't want my
house to burn down
i don't care about this kid it's him or
me see
people used to have a sense of community
and scruples and they'd be like i will
not condemn this young man
i saw the evidence not anymore you may i
think it's possible we get a hung
a hung jury maybe one person just says
no way i'm not locking that kid up for
this that's self-defense
but i think there's a stronger
possibility like we saw in minneapolis
come on you had that lady who straight
up
said i couldn't go through the riots i
didn't want to go through the riots
again
they had to escort the jurors in the
chauvin trial into the building
under armed guard with like swat team
rifles because of the riots
these people knew exactly what they were
doing said i don't care
lock them up i'm not taking this one
totally do you think the jurors and
written house
are gonna are gonna disagree they're
gonna save their own butts does that
open that
up to appeal i believe uh there's a
bunch of grounds for appeal for shoving
but what does it really do grant him a
new trial maybe
i i don't think so i mean yeah we've had
we've had we had andrew bronco on we've
had other legal experts and they just
said
it's not dude i watched written house
as live as you could possibly watch it
without being there brandon g
and a few other guys they were on the
ground richie rich
but like dude i watched it as live as
you could if
without being there it seemed completely
completely obvious we've we've had i
think
the entire uh riot squad crew that was
on the ground yeah here
at different times talking about what
happened one of the biggest clips we've
ever done
was richie mcginnis the journalist who
actually rendered aid to one of the guys
who got shot
telling his story i'm not gonna put
words in his mouth but
i've i've heard witness testimony i've
watched all the footage
oh dude clearly self defense but hold on
hold on it's not just about written now
check this out i got another story for
you you're gonna love this one uh uh
i'm gonna love it i bet elizabeth city
police arrest woman accused of striking
two protesters with her car
she's being charged with assault with a
deadly weapon with the intent to kill
wow so uh she was uh she was uh taken to
album album mary district jail with a 40
000
secured bond her first court appearance
is the 27th
they say they responded to a call around
6 45 pm
this they she she struck people with her
car i watched the video she was going
about a mile or two miles an hour
she was driving through an intersection
when the black lives matter group
started banging on her car
she then slowly drove through and one of
the one of the black lives matter
protesters
fell over and injured her leg this woman
was now arrested
and charged with felony assault with a
deadly weapon with the intent to kill by
using
i'll read it two counts of felony
assault with a deadly weapon with the
intent to kill by the use of a motor
vehicle
one count of careless and reckless and
one count of unsafe movement
remember provo utah provo utah was where
somebody was driving down the street
and a group of black lives matter
extremists ran up and one person pulled
out a gun and shot the driver
dude if a car is driving on the road and
you run towards it side
towards its side and throw yourself into
the side of the car hanging on it and
fall down and hurt yourself you can sue
them
no not anymore the woke have taken over
kyle rittenhouse
no no no as the person that throws
yourself into the car you can see
the driver of the car it used to be that
way but not if the person is a black
lives matter protester
this woman has felony charges too
you can sue the driver for hitting you
right right right right that's crazy to
me
so in dc and maybe it's like this in
other places too
people walk out into the street as an
active defiance and an expression of
power
jaywalking right like they won't go to
the crosswalks they'll deliberately walk
very slowly across the street strut and
looking at you
making you stop your car with your eyes
with their eyes in the middle of the
street right
and i don't like that very much so one
day i thought let me look up the law
on this right if a pedestrian is in the
middle of your
of your way to drive you are obligated
to avoid that pedestrian at all costs
that's the law right if they jump out
into the street
you you have to try to avoid them no
matter what even if they're wrong even
if they're committing a crime even if
it's a violation
even if you're totally right that's the
law i looked it up
because i wanted because i wanted to
yeah no because i wanted to know
it was to me this is absurd use of that
perhaps that they attacked the car yeah
this woman was physically attacked
fortunately she was safe in her vehicle
in the video i've watched it
a mile an hour two miles just slowly
creeping forward yeah
that's idling yeah yeah yeah not no i i
really doubt her
for focus on the gas at all how slow she
was going and they were jumping up and
down and banging on the car as we've
seen
now she's got two felony charges i
warned this is going to happen
how many times have i said this i love
it there's like the left likes to take
select political moments like tim's
predictions are all wrong and it's like
i got a whole bunch and so and you know
it jack
where it's like we were right about this
i said what two years ago
it's only a matter of time before the
police are like it's easier just to
arrest the victim than deal with a mob
so now you have a woman who is who is
attacked in her car fortunately safe
protected by her car
who tried escaping from a violent group
of people banging on her vehicle
and the cops said the i'll just arrest
the driver
why why am i going to support the cops
i'm sick of this
you know people saying defend the police
not sorry i'm not playing that game
i'm not going to defend anybody because
this is what they do they seize your
guns they take away your right to defend
yourself
they arrest you in your own home and
then you get kyle written out going to
jail you get the mccloskeys getting
arrested and they get their guns
confiscated you get the guys at a tillis
gym the people who are going in getting
arrested by the cops
and all of these conservatives like well
it's not the cops fault
whose fault do you think it is who
literally went and arrested this woman
and put her in jail
the d.a no the d.a said in office having
no idea what's going on
the cops showed up and said we choose to
imprison this woman for trying to flee a
violent mob of extremists
keep supporting those people and then
when you're locked up next i won't
defend you
i'll say what you you like it if the
cops come in if you
if you are walking down the street
minding your own business and blm comes
and beats the crap out of you and the
cops arrest you i'm gonna be like but
you wanted that
you support the police what jurisdiction
was this with the car
this is elizabeth city north carolina
where the riots are exactly
so the police have decided because of
the andrew brown shooting
they are going to arrest the victims of
violent crime because it is easier than
dealing with the mob
by all means keep back in the blue all
day and night and when you end up in
jail
because you were beaten up by blm i'll
say but you support the police
aren't you happy that they've locked you
up in their facility it's what you
wanted isn't it
oh i know they're letting black lives
matter go they're letting them
throw bricks through windows and beat
pedestrians and smash windows
but you support the cops actually people
don't even know
right there i think uh there was some
research that just came out about
democrats awareness of antifa none
no awareness oh oh this is this is
fantastic see i covered a couple stories
this morning
and on one of my earlier segments are
you familiar with ground news
no so ground.news they sponsored one of
my my
earlier segments and it's really a great
service this is not a sponsor spot by
the way but i did do a promo spot forum
before
they show you the amount of left wing
and right wing outlets reporting on the
story
so you look at an antifa story and what
do you get you get a bunch of
you get every right wing outlet covering
it and then they'll say left wing and go
back one
and then far left zero so of course the
left and
these these progressives have no idea i
remember
uh on the eve of the uh inauguration and
stuff
uh or jan six actually maybe like the
week leading up to that in dc
they were boarding up uh the buildings
again and
i went on facebook to talk to a couple
of my old friends of something of course
every time
i tried to explain to them that the city
had been boarded up since may 27th
and they had no idea people that
live in the city that maybe don't just
come downtown
that just go suburb the suburb or the
outer part of the city or whatever
they had no idea that there had been
riots all
summer long burning buildings multiple
alarm
fires hundreds of assaults and felonies
and loot
i was five feet away from people looting
and they just have no zero
nada knowledge or understanding so when
i come on facebook and i'm like
actually guys it's because these blm
antifa folks have been writing all
summer they're like
you're an idiot you're an ass you're
blah blah you're the worst person in the
whole world they unfriend me and they
get all mad
because you challenge what they believe
to be their like
perception of reality this is the
biggest problem
is is is is how do we get people to let
go of their ego invested sense of
reality
that they've actually fortified with
mainstream commercial news they have no
idea whether they're trusted or not it
just passively goes in their brain they
believe it
i'm anti-racist i don't know i'm not a
race it's all a perfect storm
of of trained ignorance reliance on
institutions that are no longer
trustworthy or valuable
and then an impossible task of
dislodging this fake reality out of
people's minds
and when you try to you look like the
bad guy to them
let me let me show you uh this this from
ground news is really interesting
i pulled up the story about the woman in
elizabeth city hitting the protesters
with the car
now which do you think it's left or
right reporting the story about the
woman hitting protesters
it's definitely the left and it's
definitely framed as a vehicular assault
on
you are correct but it's not the far
left it's just center to
uh center left and left sources that are
reporting this
uh the daily caller was the only
right-wing outlet to report this which i
find interesting because
typically the right does report on these
things but they frame it very
differently yeah
so what happens lefty people liberals
will open the news and go oh these
people are hitting the protesters these
peaceful protesters are being run over
so here's what i did i went i went to
ground news and i searched for antifa
surprise surprise uh all of their all of
the immediate links that pop up when you
search for anti-fun ground news
right-wing source right-wing source
right-wing source right-wing source
100 right-wing 100 right wing 100 right
wing
i'm not surprised oh yeah antifa is not
real everything's normal
this is why you see lefties and
progressives saying antifa is just an
idea
it's why you get these politicians who
are completely dumbfounded and don't
understand what's going on
but you know this is not a winning thing
this is
look dudes people i was doxed
by a woman who claimed to be antifa
who had a flag and antifa flag on her
banner from twitter
who led antifa meetings who deliberately
organized the whole operation to docs
and get me fired
and i explained this to people they're
like oh well i knew you were out of work
oh i knew you were having trouble oh but
antifa is just not no that
nope just keep it no no they put a gun
to my head
they got me finally they yes
they ruined my life literally for a
short period of time
destroyed my reputation bro but you
bruce lead it i bruce
you took their energy which again if you
turn it back on
if you do that then it also means you
didn't get canceled and it's not a real
thing and there was no negative side
effect for that
but it's like these are people that have
known me my whole life
that have been to my wedding that know
my children and yet i tell them like
this is my
personal real life experience i was
there i saw it they doxed me this flag
doesn't did you tell him with text in
person
wow in person what was their response
this is just
just this like opaque like like
film of confusion and disbelief
they can't process it because if i'm
right
that means everyone else is wrong and if
everyone else is wrong then maybe
everything else is wrong as well
do you guys remember that photo where
all the people are doing the roman
salute the nazi salute and one guy is
just all frumpy like
yeah yeah so that's us we're the frumpy
people saying i will not salute
and those people are the ones doing the
red salute marching through the street
100
they're literally doing what's called
the red salute google the red salute
look it up
the black lives matter symbol is the red
salute it is the communist symbol the
nazis may have been beaten but the
communists weren't
yep i had a conversation with my son
just the other night he's 14 years old
and he's
feeling a lot of peer pressure uh
to do certain medical procedures that we
probably don't want to talk about here
and uh i told him you know son
it's lonely doing the right thing it's
lonely
standing up and and when you're
when you're 14 it's really hard to do
that
especially when you're getting pressure
from your parents not me
family relatives cousins people in your
neighborhood your sports coaches your
teachers at school the parents of your
friends
very difficult to stand up and do the
right thing i i
i'm very proud of him he's told me
before about how
during the in the morning during the
pledge of allegiance everybody in class
just talks and like doesn't do it and
doesn't pay attention he stands up he
says he's the only one that stands up
every day for it
and so i know it's inside of him but i
know that he's struggling right now
because it's really hard
it's really hard to stand up and do
what's right when everyone around you
is doing something wrong and thinks that
they're doing something right and
they're telling you that you're wrong
and that you're stupid and you're evil
and you're gonna die
you're gonna die if you don't do this
thing
well i got good news for you i'm
sweating oh boy it's hot up here huh
from foreign policy.com lincoln
authorizes u.s embassies worldwide to
display blm flags
a new directive comes while the united
states commemorates the anniversary of
george floyd's murder
they say blinking has announced the u.s
secretary of state u.s embassies around
the world
to fly the blm flags and banners
according to an internal cable reviewed
by foreign policy as part of the
administration's response
to the one-year anniversary of the
killing of george floyd the state
state department cable gives chiefs of
missions who had us embassies and
consulates worldwide
blanket written authorization to display
blm flags and banners
as appropriate in light of local
conditions
there you go what they're going to be
flying
the black lives matter flag at our
embassies and come this is the fist that
the power fists could be they want to
the marxist
organization hell bent on destroying the
united states we are going to fly their
flag
who won who won
we have let me show you some images
so here we have black lives matter and
you can see the raised fist the red
salute
see another flag with the red salute
there's the red salute and a lot of
people say oh tim
here's here's some black lives matter
red salute red salute
and people say oh it's it just means
black power
and i'm like yeah and then nazi salute
means white power i don't care what you
think it means
when the chinese communist party swear
in a party member
they they raise their fist in the red
salute they still do
and so a lot of people don't seem to
understand that
it is the anti-fascist salute just like
the berlin wall was the anti-fascist
protection rampart
it is called that's what it was called
it's the red salute and just because
other groups have peripheral support for
uh communist ideology does not change
what that symbol means
like we mentioned this often but it's
it's ancient hinduism the swastika it
was
inverted i don't care it's a it's a nazi
symbol that's there you go
symbols can be taken over and they can
represent bad things you're not going to
come to me
and raise your your red salute to to
communist authoritarianism
and have me be like oh did you mean
something else so now think about this
american embassies and consulates will
be flying symbols of communism well they
can right that's what this says they're
encouraging the blanket authorization to
fly the flag
so yes when they raise the flag blanket
authorization
saying if you want to show your fealty
you better step up and do it it's
optional of course
optional if you don't do it then you
might as well be
that guy that got fired from space force
for saying that marxism is taking over
the military yeah i don't know where
this goes other than that
it's terrifying i am i'm a little bit
more upset tonight than usual because
i just keep thinking about i read the
text okay
the text says disrupt the nuclear family
disrupt the capitalism society destruct
just deconstruct and disrupt american
culture
it's in the freaking literature and
we're gonna fly their flag
yep what if who why isn't anybody
reading anything
these are the people who say that
america is evil as a slaveocracy
that you know whiteness is inherently
bad that being on time is bad and we're
flying their flags
i'm reading their books saying their
words and being told that i'm the crazy
one
and i'm making it up while they're
flying the gdblm
flag over our government properties yep
yeah that's reality
and i
sometimes i've just had enough i think
i'm a little emotional because of this
medical procedure thing that people are
doing right now and the pressures
i think it's just the heat in the room
people people it's like 85 in this room
right
people are feeling and and it and the
tension and the drama and the peer
pressure and the coercion and the lies
and the misinformation and the lack of
effort and the lack of agency and the
lack of personal accountability
and just pushing that all off on
everybody the whole thing is about
pushing it all off on everybody
we gotta pop this zit you know when you
squeeze a zit and it
hurts this this this critical theory
thing is like a painful zit where you
squeeze it and it hurts and it's sore
because nothing's coming out
but if you get it just right it stings
and it explodes and then no it's
normal it's wishful thinking but too
many people are cowards
too many and they're pushing them the
wrong way they're pushing and they're
bruising it and they're breaking blood
vessels because they're not getting the
stuff out
there most people are
are cowards yeah that's true republican
party especially it's comprised of like
85 percent cowards
i mean what they're they they do nancy
pelosi comes out and kevin mccarthy
drops to his feet and licks her
drops to his knees and licks her feet
and then ilhan omar comes out and says a
whole bunch of you know ridiculous
nonsense and pelosi is like she's fine
it's fine
i mean the gop establishment itself
especially so i'm not here to criticize
everybody in america but the truth is is
that like common people
again it's about where do you put where
you put your energy
and in the past it was made more sense
to focus more on things that might be a
little bit more in front of your face
but today
it makes sense to pay attention to
things that are a little bit bigger
picture
because your family is at risk your
family is at risk this is not about
different marginal tax rates this is not
about tariffs
it's not about contributions to foreign
alliances or even oil
it's about the very fundamental nature
of who we are as a country our
definitions of justice
our system of of applying prestige and
and and and resources it's
it's coming apart and people are paying
attention and no one believes it
and it's also for a large portion of
this country a question of your immortal
soul
which is one of the bigger issues i find
interesting is that you know christians
are particularly
inactive as well and many churches are
flying blm flags too like in dc
totally so they're adopting a moral
framework which
uh eschews judeo-christian values
completely yes i've heard i am not a
churchgoer but i have heard
often stories that the church has become
woke yeah well not all of them but a lot
in in a way in in that the institution
isn't really a reliable defender
of the things that we're interested in
no the church is not the catholic church
is a business and it's a business that
functions off of control
that's not and they're seating control
that's that's kind of the point
yeah i feel like these these are they're
giving up their own moral tenets
to a a moral-less framework
christianity is wonderful it has a lot
of wonderful tenets but
the church itself is a dangerous
business and there's a much bigger
church
that they're borrowing bowing to so what
do you think happens when they give all
their power to an even
worse and evil evil institution at the
very least
these churches gave us you know as i
often said blackstone's formulation
the moral framework of wokeness is
sacrifice for power
so you could be a good woke fearing
ideologue
and they will sacrifice you in a
moment's notice for power
look at that that woman on the board of
the schools in san francisco or whatever
she was ragging on asians all day and
night why because they said to because
he said asians were were white adjacent
to dead power and privilege
then they realized there was power to be
made with the stop asian hate movement
so they threw her under the bus
immediately and she fought and she
resisted and they canceled her
because she's a bigot i want to point
out and call out some people some shout
outs though
these guys in loudoun county are really
fighting for oh yeah they're
not too far from they're really fighting
for it um there's people good skatepark
there who are really
ian pryor is leading a team of parents
and they're really working hard to fight
back against this they understand
they're woke and you know what
these people in loudoun county that are
fighting this they follow me
they follow you they're listening to us
good what are they doing
fighting they're trying to recall the
school board they're trying to get rid
of all the woke stuff out of their
curriculum they're trying to
parents right their parents they're
trying to keep like advanced mathematics
and things like that they're fighting
back
so these these are not the people i
refer to when i say most people are
cowards no i know
i'm saying i want to shout these people
out i want to give them the recognition
that they deserve and i want
other people to see acts of courage
that is an act of courage what's
happening in loudoun county
follow these people do what they're
doing
use them as inspiration and honestly we
have to keep doing what we're doing
these people literally follow us
they literally read what we're saying
they listen to our videos they take it
home
and they're putting it into action kudos
to you and to everyone else who's doing
i think we both
clearly like talking so i think we're
good we'll keep doing it
i'm having i'm having mixed emotions
about it because i'm talking
i didn't drink any coffee so i'm not
stemmed right now oh and you don't have
that that that bio trust the power
get the bio trust thanks bio trust if i
was stemmed up right now i would just be
drenched i'd be in a pool of water it's
like 85
so the power because it just hopped in
like the power for those that just
popped in
the power's been out for a while we
might get cut off at any moment because
we're running on multiple batters like
multiple battery backups because we're
smart
you know over here at tim castle i just
don't know what to say about this like
i'm trying to picture a situation
where this we get this outer layer of
crusty crap
that schluffs off like the the critical
crap that just eventually we just
falls away in the united states is there
again but
i can't imagine that making it get worse
it's inevitable to make it get better
it's never been perfect it's always the
fight that we are having
has always existed civil rights the
civil rights movement was a fight for
individual liberties and you know
anti-discrimination and
a lot of these things were opposing
ideology so america's never been perfect
but the framework has been
the best we've seen right in history it
enables us to do
shows and so and and we've we've built
we've built up over hundreds of years
we've been getting better and better and
better we've had some bad moments i
think everybody really hates woodrow
wilson i think michael malus for the
most part he was like that's
he that's what he said worst president
of all time mega fascists signed the
fact yeah
federal reserve stuff so so there's
there's some there's we've been
exploited
but right now illiberal ideologues once
again
moral authoritarians are trying to seize
power and the
and the true individualists the true
classical liberals those who believe in
life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness
have to keep fighting because
authoritarians always
want to steal power it was dave smith
said that
but i think mike mouse said that fdr was
the is the worst president of all time
which i was no no no
michael mouse was talking about world
war one will woodrow wilson high school
is my local high school in washington dc
they're going to change the name to ruth
bader ginsburg high school
he wasn't the greatest yeah i i actually
like that you know
do you like that name actually woodrow
wilson seems like a pretty bad dude he's
in the federal reserve act yeah yeah
ruth bader against
our world that's probably a better trade
don't agree with her on her rollings but
you know woodrow olson seems pretty bad
federal reserve not a good thing not a
good thing so and the fed
is this partly because the government
was co-opted in the early 1900s
by the rockefeller i don't know but if
you think about it like this if you give
everybody a voice
there's enough voices saying the wrong
thing then they can make the wrong thing
be what's happening in the whole country
and that's what we're getting right now
so i wonder about the power of that
it's time to start beginning
post-liberal exploring post-liberal
options
what do you mean by that post post
whatever we got going on right now
so you think this is the democratization
of communication
has enabled bad communication the
democratization
of communication has destroyed public
residence we used to all resonate
together
mostly because we were on the same
narrative and that same narrative came
from just a handful of people
walter cronkite or whoever owned a
handful of newspapers or whatever the
case may be
jimi hendrix explosion of communication
from the many to
the many and now we are no longer in
residence and we will never be back in
residence ever again in the way that we
used to so
you know what we really need is maybe
like
uh uh if you're if a bunch of people are
watching say a political show it's live
and they're
and this is what we need to hear more of
they should share the link
they should take the link and smash the
like button and then take the link to
that show and share with everybody so
that we all get on the same page start
learning about what's going on
and uh then look productive that is not
just a cold shameless plug
smash that like button sure it is but
i just got dms right now from a parent
in loudon watching us right now saying
i'm watching you from loudon thanks for
shouting us out
if you share this show and share our
content more people will find out
and more people will step up it's not
a uh galactic size exaggeration to say
that you can help save the fate of this
country by reach
by sharing the show well well i'm it's
it's like that no you could do it fast
too
think about it this way have you ever
have you ever have you ever gone to
private mode on youtube and then
like have you ever gone like a private
tab and then opened youtube sure and
what do you see not me
no you see a bunch of weird like weird
corporate youtube
nonsense and mainstream music so regular
people aren't
seeing any of this and if people don't
know how can they
stand up to it how can they understand
why it's bad so that means if you do
know
just click share i'm not telling you go
preach on a street corner holding up a a
i'm a gorilla t-shirt being like you
must watch tim can
you should be like hey guys check out
the show let me know if you like it just
send it to three or three friends
i mean look and buy and buy books
because then they appear on the top of
the the amazon list for regular people
so you've had andy nosebook on antifa
which is really important for the people
who don't know antifa exists right you
can get his book
you've got michael malus he's got a new
book and speechless by michael knowles
available for pre-order
uh james o'keefe has several books
american pravda
democrats are deplorable that's also a
good one by one general i don't know
about that one i was not so bad
not so bad democrat i'm not trying to
tout my show too hard but i do
consistently get people saying look this
show's woefully unsubscribed and under
viewed
and i know for a fact we're having the
just like here
just top level conversations with high
level government officials philosophers
activists academics et cetera et cetera
you got to share it
we got to share it because we literally
are all in this together we'll all have
a part to play think about it this way
the uh religious say you have to preach
it seem like a core tenant of many
religions to preach and spread the word
and the woke not only do they preach and
spread the word
they threaten violence against those who
reject it so think about what we're up
against
we're saying life liberty to the pursuit
of happiness objectivity work hard plan
for the future
they say those things are bad we're
seeing the consulate fly the flag of
black lives matter
if you take issue with these things and
you believe no no no no
no no no no no if you believe that two
plus two does not equal five
then you need to start talking about
this because they are teaching your kids
your your your nieces your nephews
they're teaching them that two plus two
equals five
i'm not it's not an exaggeration they're
literally doing it they're saying
they're saying math
is a construct of whiteness science and
objectivity are a concept of whiteness
i watched a video i don't know if you
could remember this one jack where there
was a science class
and there was a woke person saying that
the the ancient
african knowledge was spiritual
awareness and it's equally as plausible
as the scientific method and people are
like oh wow you know interesting and
it's like dude
there are a lot of hidden truths that
have been ignored and rejected that i
can accept
there's like we talked about the ant
hills where they funnel heat out of the
ant colony and then you know
tribes in africa figured that out and
they could build you know houses that
were cooler
so there's a lot of things we have lost
but that doesn't mean the scientific
method a framework of control and
discovery
is whiteness it's just like math
two plus two equals four you can change
the definition of the words
you can say flub plus flub equals flop
but if they represent those quantities
in the same way it's it's basically
absolute
you could see how they might construe
physics as like white power
because the english empire used physics
to dominate the globe and established
colonies everywhere you know isaac
newton gave them the ability to fire
cannons
long range from their boats because of
physics you could calculate where it was
going to land
so they dominated the seas i was
watching for the queen basically physics
do you know uh the the maori in new
zealand they have something called
a paw i'm not entirely sure i think it's
called the paw and it's a spiral
fortress and it made it very very
difficult for european
settlers because they had to fight their
way around
in a spiral where the people inside
could use spears
through it it was hard for them to take
the fortress
going through a spiral so you know what
the the the the european sellers did
gatling guns invented in the late 1800s
that made it a lot easier
so just do that that's how lagertha
defended
cat to cut against invading tribes was
by creating like a little catacomb
outside of the city walls and they could
move walls they could pull them up put
them down and trap them and then use
their spear so it works smart
my point was if you if you you might
assume that these technologies are like
white
because the white people invented them
but anyone that wants to use physics
is going to get the same result it
doesn't play race doesn't matter this
these these
anyone that gets there on time and that
gets there early and does good work
one one of the one of the our our
abilities that allowed us to evolve was
the fact that we can throw things
right yeah what what other animals are
throwing things you see not too much in
human evolution when we learned how to
throw
monkeys throw poop and guess what and
get well
we're related true yes and guess what
and guess what
what are you doing when you pick up that
ball and you're throwing it over there
you're doing immense physics
calculations right
immense so it can't be by power and you
know what's really interesting is human
power
human power it was it was the throwing
of rocks which uh
really gave us more and more power so
first you know it's like we'd hit
somebody with a fist
then we were like i'll pick up a rock
and hit you with the rock because the
rock's harder
then somebody was like dude i'll throw
the rock and hit you with it then some
other person was like
i will sharpen that rock put on a stick
and another stick and fire it at you
even faster
and then eventually got to the point
where we were like dude i'll break up
these rocks with some bat poop
put it in this tube which is a big long
rock and then launch that rock so fast
puts a hole in your head
now we've got full auto rock-throwing
in groups and yeah and not in america
really good at throwing rocks not in
america though we
we've there's no fully automated rock
throwers in america it's just nfa
you know it's hard to get but we've
basically perfected throwing rocks at
people right they're really good at it
right we've also tricked rocks into
doing calculations for us we've
we've shaped rocks it's a dramatic
oversimplification but it's actually
it's actually what a dramatic like
it's actually opposable thumbs and the
fingers allow us to manipulate
small things so we can make circuits we
can make robots that can manipulate even
smaller objects
and we have an oxygen-rich environment
that allows us to
uh you know create fire and then extract
metals and other elements and
yeah let's not let's not forget the
nitrogen too shout out to nitrogen
75 percent of our atmosphere shout out
and it doesn't discriminate either right
it's not white nitrogen is not white i
feel like i
we have beaten this horse this this
critical rate but it has
you guys are right way it has to be
talked about i just it's not my it's not
i am i get stressed actually amazed
at the lack of understanding by
the general public and even by people
that follow me people that know me
they i keep thinking everyone knows
what's in my head they don't
yeah it's my job even as a professional
talker it is my job to talk talk talk
talk talk i feel like i'm still talking
about it too much but yet every single
day i talk about it
somebody knew it was like wow i had no
idea right
yeah everything's gonna reach somebody
every single day it's
different than telling the same person
every day yeah which can drive them
insane it can but you know like
some of my followers been with me for a
long time they know they know that i
have to tell the same stories they know
i have to do the background so people
understand why they're here they know i
have to continue to talk about all the
stuff because
it's important and so if you're really
on the cause
jack murphy live on twitter if you're
really down for the cause you tolerate
some repetitiveness because it's state
louder for the people in the back say it
louder for the new people
so this is one of the things i ran into
uh early on in youtube
that my first wrong assumptions were
that most people who subscribed were
watching every video
right and then i started getting too
many of like what was that a reference
to and i'm like okay so
then i started making sure i would
always do really quick like here's a
catch up for those that don't know and
so then you know some people were like
tim told that story like five times in
this month and i'm like because
the average so i'll produce i think what
do i do i'm doing like
three eight maybe 10 segments per day
across these channels and then of that
that's every day and that's monday
monday through friday so maybe like 250
seconds for a month
and the average person watches 10 or 15.
so how much are they missing from the
context of these conversations
the other thing that's really funny is i
get a lot of people who
they're clearly only being fed certain
videos from me
so the videos where i say something
about guns they get all of them they're
like man tim talks about gun rights all
the time and i'm like it's like one
you know once a week out of like
hundreds of segments
but youtube feeds you what you're
interested in so if you watch the videos
from me about joe biden you're going to
go on youtube all the time and just see
tim poole talking about joe biden all
the time and you're not going to see me
talking about republicans or the gop or
whatever
it's just going to be yeah twitter does
the same thing based on your likes and
preferences if you don't have the raw
feed switch that otherwise twitter is
telling you what they want you to know
jack give me some solutions dude okay so
i'm glad that you said that
because i'm sitting here this whole time
this is the questions i ask all my
guests on my show too all right
what next what do we do what do we do
and i've come up with a personal plan
for myself and my community
focus on yourself focus on your family
focus on your brothers
get with the community start a network
become part of a network
forget about the institutions build
things of meaning for yourself
ways to educate yourself ways to produce
economic activity
anything you can do to disconnect from
the leviathan maybe
maybe one thing we can do is there's a
lot of people who agree and a lot of
people who disagree and if you happen to
find yourself as someone who agrees and
you're in the city
where things are getting bad you could
maybe move to an area where
people are more likely to agree now i
know a lot of people say they can't
afford it
so maybe what we do is we start pooling
resources together
you know get all the people to live in
one area and protect it and then we'll
just make sure that everybody gets
you know some the resources they need
according to their needs and
they produce according to their
abilities and we'll start from there and
we'll expand
actually it's funny it's funny that you
should make that joke because with the
liminal order this is my all men's
network where we're doing all these
things that i'm talking about on the
ground liminal hyphen order two year
anniversary next month in june
600 members come join us uh
yeah we want to perfect collective
action but not in
this way that has those perverse
incentives in a way that's perfectly
aligned for incentives
using blockchain channel our economic
activity
in a way that produces economic activity
that funnels it back
in proportion to what you put in
not what you need or what you expect but
actually literally in proportion to what
you put in and you can do this with the
blockchain
this is our vision this is the future
we're working on it but in the meantime
we get together man we have brotherhood
we have events we have workshops we work
out we're all in shape we all squat we
all take care of ourselves we all raise
our kids
we're also creating memes and cartoons
and hashtags and it's supposed to raise
your kids
well it's funny you should say that how
many
people have uh given up that
responsibility
to the tv how many men how many men
are failing in their responsibility to
raise their children
to raise them in a way that's productive
and healthy to not dudes you go to a
restaurant and you see a family at the
restaurant
it's a family of five mom and dad and
three kids the three kids are on their
ipads mom and dad's staring at the table
it's sad and horrible i hate it those
people have given up
you know when you laugh when you make
fun of me you say
raise your kids that might be the most
important message we could get out in
america right now
you know who is it raise your kids you
know it was a good day i said i could
yell by the way before yeah
the mics are balanced now yeah you know
you know who's a good dad
hawkeye you know the avengers oh from
the avengers when he was teaching his
daughter how to shoot arrows
oh yeah that's right yeah you teach your
kids how to do practical things right
you teach them to
to you know be do archery your kids are
supposed to
learn from you too many people
especially millennials man
they're not doing that mean anything
they're not doing anything cool
my son today maxed his squat at home
congratulations buddy good to see that
almost one and a half times his body
weight forward
at 14. wow yeah kid's a beast my
daughter's killing it as well my
youngest daughter she's killing it as
well and you know what they do they
watch by example man
yep we have a gym in our house and i
work out every day they're going to work
out too
i i may have asked you this before are
they in public school yeah
are you glad about that or you talk
about getting uh if i
look one of the most devastating aspects
of divorce is losing your agency and
autonomy over your parenting decisions
[Music]
if i were not divorced and i had the
right knob and ability to just scoop
them and move them i'd be living in west
virginia homeschooling them very easily
like
years ago i would have been gone i am
unfortunately stuck where i am given
circumstances
divorce bad bad yeah really marriage
good
marriage bad what do you think marriage
done right is a beautiful thing and it
brings
it puts you in position to uh put
something greater than yourself as your
priority
what if what becomes a priority what if
you just don't agree to get divorced
i'd well you you don't have that choice
anymore sir it's called no fault
divorce and your wife can just leave you
or the man can leave you at any time for
any reason no
reasons given whatsoever none stated it
is a legal contract
that obligates one party to behavior
and not the other and it was born at a
time where you literally couldn't get
divorced unless the crime was committed
wow did you i mean up until like the 60s
or 70s
you could not get divorced unless a
crime was committed wow
because it's a contract with obligations
now it is a one-sided obligatory
contract where the other party can just
leave it any second
take the kids and demand payment
enforced by the gun of the state
overwhelmingly favoring women yes
overwhelmingly favoring women
for sure if someone leaves you and you
have kids you they can't just take the
kids right
yes how well how could that be legal
because the court gets a judge
yeah and the judge orders you was it 87
of the time some ridiculously it's
something like that but you can't kidnap
your own kids either by the way
right so like you can take like if you
have the children they could come to
scoop the children from school and then
drive off with them
you can't steal your kids you can't
kidnap your own kids you can be in
violation of a court-ordered
visitation agreement but in the absence
of that
is whoever whoever has possession
you can kidnap your own kids legally i
thought you were saying you can't like
it's illegal to do it no it's illegal to
kidnap your own kids i'm saying there's
no such thing as kidnapping your own
child
because it's not a crime it is a crime
it's not a crime there's there's no
possible way in my understanding to
quote commit the crime of kidnapping
your own child yeah there literally is
yeah so if you have a visitation i just
i just said that
in the absence of a score or a
visitation you're saying like more like
like morally
like i'm saying pre-court-ordered
visitation agreement
can you just take your kids and run away
yes oh you can't you can
it's not you can't there's no such thing
as stealing your own kids
got it until you get the device until
you get the court-ordered visitation
and then then it's in for and if you
don't do it then it's uh um
contempt yes right and so then they put
you in jail
the judge will put you in jail the judge
will put you in jail if you don't pay
the judge will put you in jail if you
don't earn as much as you're supposed to
oh wow through imputed income
yeah there's there was a celebrity who
uh was making a ton of money
and then his career kind of dried up i'm
not gonna say his name because you know
yeah personal stuff but it was there's a
big news story this guy was making a
bunch of money
his his uh child support and alimony was
like ridiculous
it's like hundreds of thousands of
dollars per month or something or knows
like tens of thousands like 50 60 000.
and now that he's not working he's broke
he's running out of money
so he petitioned the court for a
reduction in child support with
the support of his ex-wife who agreed he
can't afford this
please court will you and the court said
no what yeah
so there's a very very famous individual
and the story was a couple years ago
the guy's own ex-wife who was like they
were still cordial like they got
divorced and they're like okay we're
cool
and then he was like hey look you know
i'm not working i can't really afford to
pay then she goes
no problem and she signed a letter
saying i'm totally fine with this with
respect and the judge said no
no no the kids have to have a standard
of living that's maintained so keep
paying it and he's like but i don't have
it they're like we don't care
they don't care it's called imputed
income there's no mercy
no sympathy lost your job who cares got
doxed who cares
got doxed by a national terrorist
organization hell-bent on destroying
your life
doesn't matter if you work so if you get
married the government is not the
parents of your children technically but
if you get divorced it seems like they
are
they get to enforce whatever they decide
by the point of a gun
that's it in jail so they can kind of
tell you
but if you don't do what they say you go
to jail dude if the mom and the dad
can't decide on alimony payments
and the government decides for you
that's it for sanity that's of course
where have you been bro but that only
happens if you get married and then
divorced
if you never got married in the first
place no absolutely not dude the minute
that baby comes out you're obligated to
child support
marriage is totally totally irrelevant
yeah totally irrelevant
there are people commenting they were
like tim got this story from rogan
i got it from reddit actually what story
about the celebrity and
i mean i saw it in regular news it was a
couple years yeah yeah yeah yeah
but it's a common story yep well i mean
this one was complicated by the fact
that the ex-wife was like that's
insane and the court's like we don't
care that's insane because generally
speaking the courts
to their credit are like if y'all can
figure it out just figure it out we busy
over here figure it out
and and who knows best for the kids but
the two parents coming together into an
agreement
which is why they they always generally
say go to mediation
even go to arbitration just like get out
of the court as best as you can
we gotta go super chats if you have not
already smash that like button
i mean tim smash the like button
subscribe to this channel
and share the video if you agree and you
like the show
then i'll put it this way do you think
cnn deserves more viewers than we do no
no ian no i don't think they do well
then people need to share the show
take the url and to share that's the
most powerful thing yeah so
so right now cnn gets hundreds of
millions of views on youtube
hundreds of millions per month way more
than me or crowder or any of these
channels people don't realize that
they're like cnn's ratings in the gutter
and they're all laughing it's like yeah
it's true on tv
but on youtube they get five times what
crowder gets
cnn and you know what it is it's because
people
share those links you think i'm joking
but it is youtube
artificially props them up and then
regular people will share don lemon on
youtube
because they do so we need to displace
that we need more people sharing our
clips sharing jack's show
buying books from people like andy noe
michael malus and michael knowles and
james o'keefe and jack murphy
and now we need to read super chat share
it like generally but also if you share
with like
a specific person you know that you
think might like it that goes sometimes
even better like a general share so this
is why we started the facebook so go to
facebook.com
tim cast irl where there are clips that
have like the writing and you can just
click share
i don't like facebook i don't know who
does like facebook who are these people
who go on the play store and give
zuckerberg five stars i don't get it
but there are a lot of people on
facebook and that's where they get their
news
so if we can use that and leverage that
to get people to come to timcast.com
to come and watch these shows we gotta
compete now ben shapiro and dan bongino
and fox news do
really well in terms of shares but we
need some balance don't we
we need a real debate we need more so if
you like the show and you think we do a
good job
just share share share all right here we
go spread your base
spread the bastedness fellas william
leverett says first time listener long
time caller
i used to think tim poole was kami trash
now i couldn't imagine my life without
him me too keep it the good work guys
love you
uh well you know it was funny because we
did this video
where i take the guns and we go we got
shooting at the range and people like
tim will never admit he's right-wing
and then people were quoting because i
said i've actually moved further left on
the political compass test
that's all true but i'm like at the
bottom of libertarian and so
if if you're if you're a libertarian to
the
updated degree it doesn't matter if you
ideologically believe cooperation is
better than competition
because the the underlying ethos says
leave me alone and i'll leave you alone
so then when i see like ron paul and
rand paul i'm like i like those guys
because they want to leave me alone
and then i can have my hippie farm where
we can all share and you know lay in
hammocks
and you guys can you know sell water to
each other
ian's not even wearing shoes this is the
hippie commune already
not today not ever well technically
jack's not wearing pants either i'm not
oh my gosh
and at home on my shows i don't actually
wear
anything i love the 21st century all
right all right anymore
hairy toe says no luke i puke luke
abandoned us okay
luke got up and left he's gone
you know why wow it's funny luke luke's
luke's super like
and cap libertarian right but ron
desantis is running a good ship
so he goes to florida ronda i have i
have good news i'm not sure if i'm
allowed to say
on that front luke's trying to come back
your eyes open no he's not allowed
that's why he abandoned us this chair is
awfully comfortable
oh snap that sounds like a challenge no
it looks like
it looks like maybe he and i should do
it but when he comes back he's gotta
like we're gonna make him wash the
floors for for abandoning us yeah
he has to sit on the green bean bag for
it yeah he's been in the corner for a
while
all right omg puppy says get a generator
such as generac fueled by liquid propane
or natural
gas yes brilliant we we have been down
this road
and there are a few challenges first is
you know the economy is kind of on fire
so it's really difficult to actually get
this done but we all
we are already set up to do that there
are other
issues in just getting the labor
getting the materials and it's taking
forever
so in the meantime what i did was
because we've i've now gone twice
to get a generator because i knew it was
going to happen the power's still out so
we got these batteries
they're awesome and then i bought a
regular gas generator from like home
depot or whatever
and then while we've been talking people
have been setting that stuff up so we
should be good
but i've been trying to get set up with
a legit home generator it's not easy
i i feel like the temperature in the
room is coming down even ac is running
you know there's been there's been like
uh no offense
there's been like little stage hands
crawling around this whole time
guys like out of the corner i'm talking
like what the hell is
like a guy he's rolling around doing the
worm on the ground like
plugging things in you guys should have
seen it though right here it's like 7 30
we're doing the pre
the pre-show prep and boom lightning
thunder everything like power's gone
and in two seconds man team tim poole
just
scrambled like crazy there's batteries
all over the place there's daisy chained
to this the computer's up we've got 98
minutes of ac
it's like stream team dope they're like
going through all the options we can
plug in the truck we can get the
generator
where's the diesel we are compared are
prepared and we're having beans for
dinner right after it's great
just beans we've got a bunch of bins of
30-year beans
and vinegar oh yeah ian bought a bunch
of your beans
to go with your frozen flowers i don't
think you gotta freeze it by the way
we gotta we
we are a great team though crystal mac76
says hey guys i watched your recent
videos
poor dumb chickens the the next vlog
coming up this weekend is fantastic
because we got a new chicken dorothy
and she gets cancelled by the other
chickens oh yeah
yeah poor dorothy well she's not the
white one i saw in there
dorothy is a plymouth barred rock and
she's older
and so all of the so that the chickens
are basically they're xenophobic
right yeah so they all grip together and
this outsider comes in she's like an
immigrant from another farm and they're
just like not having any of it
so they're not getting along it's really
sad because she'll walk up to their
chickens and lay down and then the other
chickens will all scream
like they'll all go right then run away
it's like she didn't even do anything
dude
she just like walked over real slow and
went like and then sat down and they
freaked out
xenophobic chickens man she's sad that
chicken's sad that made me sad just now
i'm gonna go say goodbye yeah better go
talk to her dorothy yeah that's right
dorothy
all right let's see the otaku chicago
says tim mentions old country buffet
me cries because it's gone forever oh is
it oh
no is it oh that's sad i'm cb
k lorraine says jack feed the pup a
teaspoon of colloidal silver
put it on a treat and her stomach should
chill i've tried it with my
cane corso it works great you've got a
cane corso
incredible eating jelly dude i want one
of those
beautiful dogs how do you make them stop
wanting to eat that's the thing
she eats so many of the cicadas that
just the sheer volume
needs to be expelled i believe that's
really funny all right brandon schroeder
says tim for those graduating high
school or just looking for a career
change
i can't recommend going to trade school
enough i'm a survey technician and can't
recommend a better job working outside
it pays extremely well
yeah i had a i have a friend who was
very adamant about doing trades work
not complicated not a lot of money but
has meant his his mentality was
i don't want to dedicate all of my time
to my job where i'm constantly consumed
body and mind
he was like i want to think about what i
want to think about i want to think
about music and games and sports
so he likes working with his hands where
while he's doing just tasks and building
things
in his mind he's thinking about the
things that he enjoys like he was like i
free up my mind
all day i sure hope he's not using a
table saw
no that's like hvac stuff but i'm like i
get it you know
dude it's legit like i'm consumed 24 7
by all of this
when i'm not working i'm sitting there
reading news or talking about projects
my days off are now filming the vlog
it's just 100 consumption of everything
you know
so i totally get that ono comey says
i'll give another five dollars if each
member of the tim cast irl show kisses
jack right on top of his handsome dome
no i'm on it no ian says no
no one's already kissed me on my cheek
keep your money he's right
rob lowe robs low says david chipman
took a selfie during the waco incident
with the burned down building in the
background absolutely disgusting
abolish the atf yeah chipman is the
wacko waco
the waco that's right the waco that's
the guy
yeah that's the dude yep how many how
many lows could rob lowe rob if rob lowe
could rob lowe's
did it i love it no i screwed up in the
beginning
nimitz says tim bring up chipman's waco
trophy picture he posed in front of the
charred remains of women and children
for a goddamn trophy picture
i'm saying it's darth vader is that
picture dude watch it like
read the the star wars extended universe
realize that he
i knew that but i i've forgotten to make
that connection
which makes his uh avoidance of the
assault rifle definition all the more
galling
given that they were the atf they were
there was all about yeah
firearm violations and very clearly
darth vader bro according to snopes no
this is not a photo of biden's atf
nominee david chapman
interesting three hours ago and what did
they add like dot dot dot with an ice
cream cone i don't even want to click on
it it was him but he did not have ice
cream at the time
so i don't trust snobs but yeah he was
in some other county
yeah but he did the same thing i don't i
look i don't care about the photo to be
honest
yeah he's the he's that like come on
these are the guys
right all right john holman says
canada's about to pass bill c-10 which
gives the crtc
the power to regulate all online
canadian generated content this also
includes your social media feeds
i urge all canadian viewers to contact
their local mp sign a petition anything
we can't let this sneak by well don't
worry
um um you can still watch american
content on youtube
for now this is the snopes yeah i mean
they are sorry
they regulate the amount of foreign
content that goes over their airwaves in
canada oh really yeah
because well right so they live next to
the greatest content creation
uh society of all time and if they want
to have their own content
they actually have to put like actual
physical barriers
and tariffs effectively on foreign
content so that they can have
you know local canadian content so this
idea of not being able to watch
dot com youtube uh in ca actually
makes some sense to me and seems in line
with what their current policies are
i i got to read this snopes thing okay
so instead of the the claim as a
photograph shows david chipman u.s
president joe biden's atf nominee posing
before the charred ruins
of the branch davidian compound waco
1993 miscaptioned according to snopes
the context says
the photograph in question is genuine
however david chipman said during a
hearing to confirm his nomination as atf
director in may
of 2021 that the photograph does not
show him or any atf agent
wait wait that's their that's their
response what he said
said he said it wasn't him therefore it
wasn't him therefore
the the whole thing has been
miscaptioned oh okay i see i see it is a
photo of someone of an atf guy
staying in front of you he said david
chipman said it's not an atf agent or
him
but the photo is genuine looks an awful
lot like it well that's
okay well maybe it's not him oh there
you go all right or maybe it is
you gotta parse those words very
carefully homework yeah
all right kd law says if a state does
things to hurt counties and forces the
counties to stay in that state then the
counties are an abusive relationship
with the state
the state being the abuser is forcing
the counties against their will to stay
in a relationship they don't want to be
in
and continues to hurt them i agree and
they should be able to just be like we
the people
choose our own governance you no longer
have the consent
rob graf says you need an auto standby
generator
you can get a 22 kilowatt generator
transfer switch and install for less
than 8k
runs on propane that never go bad hit me
up for info
we've talked to a bunch of people
there's two big problems it's a very big
production facility
so we've already talked to one company
that said you can't
if you did it would only be for like one
portion of the house
right and it wouldn't be the one we need
right it's not like you're just running
a refrigerator and one ac
unit in this month well 22 kilowatts is
legit yeah the problem is
we have i think like five or six
breakers and so they're like we can
supply one of them
oh so we have to get a diesel generator
which is like bigger industrial and loud
and would be like a legit installation
yeah maybe i don't know but
we're probably going to do uh
what we want to do what we tried doing
last year
was solar panels and tesla battery
backups the tesla batteries could last
for four days
on a large for the entire city which is
massive the problem is
we don't have the proper exposure for
solar
so we it was like
if we did it we wouldn't really we would
have the battery backups i guess
but we wouldn't be generating anything
substantive in terms of solar so it's
like
it wasn't worth the money wow it was
really really expensive
so what are we facing north out the
front door or something
it is uh west yep no it's facing north
north and south
that is north which means we couldn't
get any proper production because the
whole
the hill but if we get the venue rebuilt
with steel which we've been trying to do
since then which is impossible right now
then we can do a beautiful east to west
exposure solar panel
which will fix everything over the
garage yeah because the garage
faces east and west which means they
were like the solar guys were like oh
that would be huge you you'd
you'd generate so much you'd kick back
to the to the grid probably
and so we were like great next thing we
got to do is go to find a company to
redo the building with steel so it can
support it and
it's been impossible really just no
labor
no parts everyone's either overbooked or
uh uh
the rates are uh like we're willing to
pay because it's expensive steals
through the roof and labor's through the
roof
but everyone's over booked or it's just
hard to like there's no one working
you know nobody's nobody's doing it dang
but
we'll try and figure it out the other
issue too is
there's only so much time in the day for
me to actually solve this stuff
and unless i'm doing it it's not getting
done so
all right let's read some more what do
we got
team buzzard says actual caliber of a
22lr for a ruger 1022 is from 223-2255
that guy doesn't know what he's talking
about or he's just duplicitous
black czar says today the trial of kyle
rittenhouse was set for november 1st
yesterday the u.s state department flew
black lives matter banners and embassies
worldwide
tragically for rittenhouse he has roused
the ire of the most powerful union
between media and state that history has
ever seen
yes life in prison smash that like
button if you haven't already support
the show
all right heavy awesome human says you
dudes are clearly sweating and getting
uh
red because of the heat here's a couple
of bucks for a cold one thanks for the
effort i think we
do have some cold cold ones the fridge
may have lost power but they're still
chilling the water was still cold
water was cold thank you beers are
delicious
sweaty therese larfield says yep i was
one that wasn't paying attention
working bringing up a family i only just
discovered youtube hence
here i am love your content gen x uh a
you
jack is cool thank you for gen x full
life
these freaking millennials
d3 fec says so the left expects us to
understand the whole gender argument
that was implemented three or so years
ago yet they don't understand the gun
argument implemented 250 years ago that
sounds fair
hayden says just got my approval for a
loan for 40 acres of off-grid mountain
forest land
seven miles outside a 200 population
town and up a mountain 13 miles from a
massive lake
that has a stream and a spring and 400
foot elevation change
going to build by hand but leaving texas
for the mountains that sounds
awesome congratulations get some
satellite internet
jelly earth linking me baby yeah
starlink i would say yeah start like
earth like i think is regular satellite
earth link was like one of the first
online internet providers i believe
the first isps back there was aol yeah
seascape uh we got this one from cp
who says tim i live in nc in about four
hours outside of ec
i was reading local news about how the
woman who hit the protesters has a
racial criminal history
look it up and let me know your thoughts
see yes
she was reportedly reported to have had
a criminal history but uh
isn't the left supposed to be about
andrew blake
jacob jacob blake yeah right criminal
history
criminal history into active committee
crime they're on scene committing a
crime
all these crimes he gets shot by the cop
committing a crime but everyone's like
oh you kid
exactly you can't consider his past
behavior
all right chris van durham says flying
the blm flag is the biden admin counting
heads minimalist ubi with a card that
limits purchases to necessities and
remains even if you work
if you have needs you work for once work
uh working also grants your vote
first sc all right
james lamb says tim we need to protest
for grandmothers in solitary confinement
for taking a police guided tour of the
capital
we have to start taking a stand before
we continue to lose ground
republicans like to use the language of
the left and that gives them everything
so they resist a lot of it critical race
theory but look at autonomous zones
it's an anti-autonomous zone why because
antifa called it that no it's a no-go
zone
those are no-go zones george floyd
square
no violent no-go zone murder criminal
hotbed criminal criminal no go zone yeah
violent
anarchy murderous failed state it's not
antarctic
it's the authoritarians who have seized
control
you give anarchists a bad name jack
sorry
i learned something every time i'm on
this show yeah real anarchists are the
ones who are like i'll leave you alone
if you leave me alone
leave me alone you know they don't want
anyone have authority over them they
want to be left alone
that's just leave me alone so here's
here's what happens you get these
leftists who are like we're anarchists
because we don't believe in the
government but we'll use force to take
what we want i'm like yeah that's
authoritarianism
like you believe you have the right to
take whatever you want and no one can do
anything to you
anarchists are like hey if you leave me
alone i'll leave you alone
perfect deal and then left anarchists
are like if we cooperate
we'll live together peacefully and right
anarchists are like i'll just give you
money in exchange we'll trade
there you go everybody leaves each other
alone until someone gets hungry
it's really just a scale issue all this
is about scale
john john alexander says i really
appreciate your honest and transparent
perspective
we need to get our messages together and
out there to the people faster thank you
the fastest way to do that is if imagine
this 30 000 people watching this right
now and and with all the views we
usually get like a total of like a half
a million with live viewers and vod
if they all shared it every single time
it's it's it it's i mean no one does no
one does well they do
they definitely a lot of people do but i
mean like imagine if
every single person who ever imagine if
every single person who watched gave one
dollar
imagine if this show was pulling in half
a million dollars per day because half a
million people watch it they said here's
a dog that's why the internet is so
powerful but they don't
do it but they can that's the point you
can share it
you can create a movement with one piece
of media the virality but the potential
to have
99 million views is there i'll say this
not even to me imagine if every single
person who watched a project veritas
video because they get millions
just gave james one dollar and veritas
you give them money you donate to those
guys i made that joke that james has got
you know too many spines he's going to
need back surgery to fix his back he's
got his spine's too big
so it really is remarkable to me
that out of the hundreds of thousands of
people who would watch a video
you know if they really want the change
there's very
it's it's it's you you barely got to do
anything click share
boom share does it share does it before
i got into the youtube game and
started production these types of pleas
would drive me nuts
to be honest who cares smash the button
i'm watching the show that's good enough
but what we're talking about here
actually is about making societal change
we're actually trying to inform people
to have better outcomes for their lives
and for their kids
so do it for them do it for them it's
interesting new media too because
pumping pimping out your own stuff or
pumping out your own stuff is like
cringy you know that's why you have an
agent when you're an actor you don't
want to go tell people hey come that's
the agent's job is to pump up this is
culture work but now it's like a
different media it's a different time
it's a different media form
you really have to kind of well there's
produce your own stuff
this is not a minecraft show this is a
our our
our country is on fire our values are
under threat and people say every day
what can i do
if you don't want to share this show you
can share stephen crowder and you can
make
michael knowles you can share people
like jimmy dore you've got to agree with
everybody
but the people who are challenging
establishment if you're like what do i
do dude if everybody who watched
any piece of content imagine if every
one of stephen crowder's viewers were
like here's steven here's a doll here's
a dollar for the day
i mean the dude be making millions of
dollars per day i liked he'd rival
fox news and abc and cnn i used to do
video responses a lot and it was like
rather than share your video if i really
liked it i would respond to it with a
video
so you would see a link to the video
it's basically like i was sharing it
by creating something look i understand
that this
content if you share it might get you
canceled if the wrong person sees it
i understand that there's a risk to what
we're talking about there's a risk to
this content these ideas are dangerous
that's why they're being suppressed
that's why people get canceled so i get
that guys if you're
if you're in a precarious position but
just tell one of your closest friends
at the same time you should make as your
number one priority in life
reducing your dependence on the
leviathan and separating yourself from
the system so that you
can be yourself so you can live
your values on a daily basis once you
get there
it's like heaven on earth i swear to god
bliss all right michelle s says i beg to
differ with jack in regards to multi-kid
families not having time to keep up with
current events
it's laziness i'm a single mom of four
kids yes life is crazy busy
and i fall into bed exhausted every
night but i sleep so well living in
reality and being prepared
amen amen and you're lucky because you
found a straight
concentrated dose of the red truth the
good truth
not everybody has that but good for you
and we appreciate it joshua vaught says
hello tim cass from new jersey what do
you all think about the cicada swarms
coming to the northeast usa
been doing pest control for about a year
this ought to be interesting since
they're emerging
since it's their emergence time by the
way it's pronounced vote cheers
we went out today and we just had a jar
and we were slapping cicadas in like
crazy
in 10 minutes i had like 30 or 40. i
just walked along the trees going dude
just the harvest man and then i chucked
them into chicken city
and the chickens ran in and they were
just like slamming their faces in this
case in case
bodies are exploding and they're just
gobbling them up and then
the second time we did it chickens
weren't comfortably full
they were like they just looked at him
and like pecked them and then just like
walked away like oh
man dude i'm too many too much i noticed
the sound like
it came about a week ago that the alarm
oh yeah it's like this
this is going to get louder all singing
yeah this is nothing sounds like i i
remember
2004 it was so loud that you
was hard to have a conversation with
somebody just standing right with them
great i think that you got louder today
it's going to get louder and louder
until
they're coming out of the ground more
and more and waiting time
and they're dying they only live for a
few weeks to bang
uh and then they have much babies so
that's gonna get louder and then they
slither in could you
check this out could you imagine being
like
you know like a native tribe like
limited technology and communications
and you're like the first emergence
happens when you're like two or three
so you don't have any idea then you're
you're 19 or 20 and you've got a family
and you're like a leader
in your local community of the small
group of 100 and you're looking for food
one day and also you hear this crazy
noise emerging
and then it's just like for three weeks
you have big baskets full of cicadas
you're roasting them and you're like we
got all this food we're eating like
kings
manna from heaven yeah for just this one
time 17 years
are these the law and they're gone are
they locusts no they're not what's the
difference
loca grasshoppers are locusts so the
locust swarms where they would come and
eat the crops
would the cicadas do the same thing oh
yeah cicadas eat they feed off tree
roots for 17 years
they emerge bang dye do they kill the
trees that they feast off of the roots
on
i don't know jack is saying no no no all
the trees in my yard have holes all
around them where they come out of the
ground and all the trees are still alive
so maybe they do kill them but not you
know but it's they don't come every year
it's everywhere
no they do there are broods every year
this is brood x
which in this region of america is the
17-year swarm
it's the big one oh awesome yeah so like
in chicago you'll hear the cicadas
definitely
all the time yeah but the big emergence
is like once in a while
balthazar says always great when you
have jack on the show here's some of my
diamond hands money you all should
definitely come visit texas i miss uncle
eddie luke
i'll be on i'll be in austin later this
fall oh
what are you doing on austin tour
liminal order world tour to celebrate
the two-year anniversary liminal hyphen
order dot com
cool scar says anthony cumia a radio
host on siriusxm had an ex-wife with no
kids and was still made to pay hundreds
of thousands of dollars in spousal
support
wow that's anthony from opium anthony
yeah
the lifestyle to which i've grown
accustomed now there are
like if you build a business together
and she stays home and doesn't work and
adds value to this business that you're
building i understand that there is a
good claim there
but when the wife is working she has her
own career and she just wants that money
i don't know caper 2x s have you looked
into a tesla powerwall
as a backup to the backup it depends on
if you can get it independently but
i don't think you can it would be really
cool though the power walls are these
big batteries so we actually had the
people come out
and they were like we're going to drop a
plan for you the initial plan they gave
us was amazing
and then they came back and we're like
after further review we realized you
could do like one panel it was like
a few panels that would generate almost
no juice and it would take like a month
to charge the batteries up
what if we had just like six tesla
batteries that
charged with the regular power so i said
it depends on if you're allowed to do
that
oh because elon said that they're only
selling them bundled or something oh
yeah yeah it's it's tough and it's tough
we can
the roof redone with steel so for a lot
of reasons
so that it can support solar panels i'd
love to do it
it's just been i mean the economy is in
shambles joe biden's like dishing and
making it rain and nobody's working
gang stuff track media only says we need
someone that gathers as a
someone that gathers as a job to take
time to put together a cheat sheet
things people can show others important
points of how they are lying blm 16 19
etc
have this fake info to use as proof
saying all of history is too vague
newdiscourses.com's got a lot of stuff
like that yep
all right we'll do a couple more
claymore says hey dudes had a theory
been brewing for a while
it basically goes like this you are
becoming the nwt
canada both politically and economically
good luck
what is that and what is the ut
northwest territory i don't know
is that that means i just had to write
it out in this table i just don't
understand
shoot the whoop says ian what do you
think about biphenylene
phenylene newly found carbon network
which has a metallic properties
i've never heard of that before i'm
looking up now yeah northwest
territories
all right let's see uh lingus rob says
read thomas sowell's conflict of visions
all right here we go we'll do one more
chukka says first super chat and jack is
looking jacked tonight nothing but a
peanut
is that a compliment i don't know yeah
jack's looking jack i'll take it
the peanut part i don't know dude i've
been following your twitter you're
posting squat
pictures we're getting impressive we're
getting good things are moving man
we're encouraging me to do the same
summer time baby summer time
white boy summer yes
if you want to get to the point where
you have that same vigor as
as jack murphy then you need to go to
timcast.com and become a member to get
access to exclusive members-only
segments you'll be enlightened
uh we recently had to go through and
re-upload all of our videos some got
lost
because vimeo deleted our account what
so we we went over the bandwidth
allotment and i got contacted by vimeo
and they're like hey you're using too
much bandwidth and that's a legit
complaint you know so it's like okay
i didn't realize we had we got way more
viewers than we thought we were going to
get
and so i said is it can you give me some
more time to figure this out they're
like we can upgrade you it's
ridiculously expensive
so we chose a competitor i guess they
got really mad
and they were like we're gonna delete
your account and i said i will keep
paying
and we'll just have this as storage if
that's okay and said no
rude and then boom deleted so then
however
instantly without without a formal a
final warning or anything like
in 24 hours and 48 hours i just woke up
today and it's like
people are emailing like yo the videos
are down and i look and it's like your
account has been deleted for you know
bandwidth violations and i'm like dude
i would have given them the money they
wouldn't let me do it i asked like three
times can i just give you
the money for this because we're going
to use a different service it's cheaper
and i guess they got mad that we're
going to competitor petty build build
your own internet but anyway go to
teamcast.com become a member we're now
using a new uh
video player and i think the ad the ad
blocker is that still blocking if you
use a brave ad blocker you might have
trouble
no i don't think that's i don't think
that's a thing that was the case a
couple i don't know i don't think really
i was having that problem i turn up
adblocker and it works everything it
seems to be fine
awesome but uh if i guess that's that's
if that happens
yeah i turned off my brave ad blocker
and was able to see videos i saw
comments a couple days ago about it
oh there you go so uh go to facebook.com
timcast irl you can share our clips
there to help spread the word and get
people to watch the show
you can follow us on instagram tim cast
irl you can follow me all over the place
at timcats on every platform
we're live monday the friday at 8 pm so
we will be back tomorrow
again we got a bonus segment coming up
with the power out we'll see what
happens
jack i hear that you have a show i have
a show jack murphy live we do a show
almost every friday
uh live at noon sometimes on tuesdays
and thursdays also jack
murphy live youtube.com jack murphy live
also jack murphy live all over the
internet instagram facebook twitter i'm
primarily on twitter
but if you're interested in brotherhood
masculinity
and sovereignty and you want to crew
come down to the liminal hyphen order
dot com check it out two year
anniversary membership opens on monday
hey you can also follow me at ian
crossland.net uh i met ian crossan
across social media i also have some
music online you guys can check out i
think it's on
itunes and amazon music spotify
just look up ian crossland let me know
what you think guys very cool always a
good night when we have jack i am for
one very excited about white boy summer
even though you might say
that i have no right to be so and the
patrons ain't a white boy song we need
you we
got a boy white boy summer is incomplete
without the white girl summer component
that's right that's what i'm saying
anyway you guys can follow me on twitter
at sour patch liz and my quest to have
more followers than sour patch kids
that's going well we will see you all at
timcast.com an exclusive members only
segment thanks for hanging out we'll see
you then bye guys
you